Right back.
We're back. Perfect. Amy on point.
Right? That time when the round starts,
I like how they're doing that. Well, they
have like a, a seven eighths commercial.
Pretty Rhonda rousing.
All right. Second round. Very interesting.
Who's better than herb dean as a referee?
I say no one and it's good. I see.
I think he's the best big. John
McCarthy gets a little bossy.
I've seen that happen a few times.
The hardest I got to bring this up.
The hardest one I ever saw was a,
uh, I wanna say Frodo versus Marlin.
Sandro. Uh, there was a nut shot
and John says, I don't think no.
Was that bad. You have two minutes. Yeah.
When I'm there going, you can't do that.
It makes sense as the commentary.
I have to explain that the referee just
said something that doesn't make sense.
Doesn't make any sense. Thank
[inaudible]. Can't do that Jeremy.
Just tag cub with a nice right hand.
So that's the knock on, on big John.
How bout this? This Strauss fight.
When James Strauss fought Bobby,
Bobby Green and Bobby Green
kicked him in the nuts two times.
Had Him hurt bad then kicked him
in the nuts a third time so hard.
You can hear the cup or the palm heard
the pop of the cup and big John said it
was a gut shot and stopped
the fight and you know,
I think knew that he fucked up
but just didn't want to admit it.
That was a mistake. That
was just a mistake. I mean
everybody makes mistakes. Yeah.
Especially when you're in something
like you're refereeing in MMA.
I mean he's still one of my all time
favorites and he did a great fucking job.
Popped him again. He's a monster
man. He's just hit so hard.
He smiled at them and they
touch gloves afterwards.
Yeah. Jeremy's power. That
fucking power or something, man.
Okay.
Oh, when he goes to the body there,
the problem is if your cub Swanson,
you'd have to stay busy cause
you gotta outland the guy,
you can't go one for
one with Jeremy Stevens.
Well he's doing a lot of thinking
and he's thinking a lot. Yeah, yeah.
He's got to do a lot of thinking.
You've got this fucking
monster in front of you.
So that's the problem is you have to
stay busy to Atlanta, but you don't,
you can't leave a vulnerability for go.
It's that hard. You just can't. Yeah.
And he's quick. Yeah. Jeremy's not slow
and he's, he was not counter fighter too.
He's not just an aggressive guy.
He's good at setting shit up.
That was a nice inside leg kick.
He's really come a long way since
he went to alliance to Eric Delphia.
I was doing a great job with him.
Okay.
It's just, it's so fucking
huge to have good coaching.
You've been with Oyama
your entire career now.
I started with Chris Brennan and
then I left Christmas to go to Jeremy
Generation. Tim Ngi, next generation.
Back in the day of those guys.
I was a fucking kid, you know, I
just [inaudible] he's right now.
He's in trouble. Damn. That
was a hard fucking punch.
Oh Shit. Holy Shit. She's not smiling at
this one now. Then he smiles. Yeah, Dude.
Jeremy Stevens can fucking bang.
Wow.
Okay.
COMP is a, it's gotta be very careful.
He looks all tentative now too, right?
He, I would, I would be, yeah, he's
got fucking cracked a couple of times,
especially Jeremy at one 45
carrying all that power down
is in a weird thing. Power. It's like you
can't really eat, can only teach so much.
You can teach a guy to hit harder,
but you can never teach a guy
to be like a Tommy Hearns.
You either have that
shit or you don't see,
my brother got the power in the family.
He hits a fucking truck, but I just,
I don't know.
I didn't get it. It's
weird isn't it? You just,
either you get it or you
don't like a joke. Oh,
we tried that cartwheel kick again.
Like a guy like George Foreman,
you can never teach. I got a
punch like that. They just, they,
you could either do it or you don't.
So strange because you can get
a guy stronger. You can lift
weights and you can be physically strong.
You can take it to it. Like you said,
you can take it to a certain degree in
teach you gotta really turn over a punch,
stuff like that, but right. Yeah.
But you can never develop a
Pino Quavis left hook. No. Uh,
you have that Hook because you have that
power. It carries through technique.
And what's your technique?
It's better.
You just punched fucking harder and
better. Yeah. You just get better.
But there's certain guys like they
have that rocky Marciano thing. Yeah.
That Marsianno Jersey Joe
Walcott and knock out,
there's like a classic
photo up against the rope.
His arm's hanging there and he sees
conveyancing Walcott's face and walkouts
faces all distorted like
Marsianno had that creepy power,
that weird thing. They were guys can just,
just fuck your world up with one shot
and you either have that or you
don't. It's weird, you know,
great fighters who go their entire
career without that one weapon.
You know, Jeremy, Steve and shoots
her, it gets a take down too.
That was one of the things that core mia
was talking about in the breakdown was
a Steven should threaten with
a take down or to just to, uh,
just to keep cub Swanson thinking
it's freezes people up a lot, man.
Yeah.
And he's right in front of his corner too.
There's the active yarrow right
in front of the alliance team.
Great fucking team in San Diego. It's
a good round for Steven's. Huge round
cubs wants, got a bunch of roses on
his leg. It's an interesting choice.
Ooh. Now they're good, right? Yeah.
I would like to hear what a
cubs corners telling him, man.
I would love to hear
what they have to say.
Wonder what kind of
advice they're giving him.
You know what a what an accident
is Jackson using? Is He?
That was hilarious. That Russian accent.
I think they have a game that they play.
Oh my God likes it when he talks to
him like that. Thinks it's funny.
At least that's what he said.
He's doing his best
fucking lock impression.
That was a big fucking wind for Henderson.
Beaten Hobby Loft. Yeah. Finishing him.
Yeah. Finishing it with
a rear naked. Yeah,
just lower down. When we don't
deliver that lower Napo come on back.
Come back to the fucking
lower down and come back with something.
Look at this
Jeremy Stevens, a mother fucker, and
that's that right hand over the top.
They're really clipped him
two big rounds for Jeremy Stevens,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Jimmy looks fucking good man.
Yeah, it's gotta be the beard.
It's a little bit of everything,
man. He's just, he's amped up man.
The kids motivated round three should
see when he wakes up in the morning with
his kids,
fire it up five or six in the morning.
But it's shame.
That was all you used to go down there
and just what he does and oh yeah.
If it gets up at like six and they
see him as kids are fucking chant and
marching around the house
cooking breakfast. They
say fire it up, fire it up.
Really? And Shane didn't wake up
early, so that's what he does.
So he's got like a champ that he
does in the morning. Wow. Oh it did.
Just to get his kids up out
of bed. Oh, that's hilarious.
My mom used to sing and I was
like, mom, get out of my room.
You are an early morning person.
Stop it.
I don't believe there are early,
early morning people.
There's people that just wake up earlier
than you and they want you to think
they are early morning people so
they have some sort of edge on you.
No.
If you have no reason to get,
if it's Sunday and you're up at five in
the morning like my mom are and you love
that Shit,
you are an early morning person.
She will get up at five five
30 on a Sunday for no reason.
That's ridiculous. Hey,
that's ridiculous. My daughter woke me
up at like six dad will sleep till noon.
I don't know how they
ever spoke to one of you.
My kids will climb on top of
me at five in the morning.
Started asking me questions. Yeah, and
I'm like, go away. They're so cute though.
Go hang out with GRANDPA. My four year
old, she would just touch my face. Daddy,
give me kiss. Oh, you're cute. And
so sweet. Can we go in the pool?
Five of the vulgar morning. You want to
swim? Nice, right hand. The right hand.
I knew better than trying to wake
my dad up at six in the morning.
I got thrown through a window.
I got to seriously,
my dad did not play one daughter
who is a fucking princesses.
Me and my dad living in the house.
So she's just got us fucking
wrapped around her finger. She just,
I'm like, oh go get a, she awakes
two and a half should wake up,
take her diaper off coal.
Come try and wake me up and a up
with a nice right hand there man. Oh
he is hurt another right hand. Yep. Oh
now can you, oh Jeremy Ryan. He's stunned.
He is and he's still trying to protect
that body yet. It's still hurting.
He can't bring his right hand up cause
he's keeping the oval down there.
He's reacting from the body and
cubs season goes from the left hook.
He went with the left hook upstairs.
Okay.
And he brought it from down low cut.
Oh right hand.
Oh beautiful.
That's the accuracy of cub.
He's got such good accuracy and that's
something you saw on the Seaver fight.
Oh good takedown defense to Jeremy's a
little bit of trouble seeing breed there.
Just trying to breathe to get those the
flow back to his lungs because he is
a body shots taken everything out of him.
Okay.
Yeah.
That body shot really fucked him up man.
That kick and cubs switching that
stance against to looking forward again,
looking for that left
kick cub needs a recharge.
There were no obvious with that left here.
Throw that thing just hit the body cause
whether they can block it because even
if you block it you're hurting.
Yeah.
Well I think he was throwing it up high
just because he figured he was going to
protect his ribs at all costs. Jeremy's
still hurting, man. He's still hurting.
You see the power difference.
Cub landed some great shots in sequence
in Gi clinic. Get Steven's office feet.
Yeah
man.
Interesting fight. Very interesting. Very,
very interesting and interesting to see
what kind of damage Jeremy is sustained
from that kick to the body.
You know a lot of guys get broken
ribs from that kick to the body a lot.
Do you remember that Heath
Herring Cro cop picture? Yup.
There was a picture of a cro cop where
he threw a left body kick and it's
halfway into heath herrings,
abdomen.
It literally looks like he got thrown from
a car wrapped around a telephone pole.
Like, Whoa, who is it?
Who did he leave the, the,
the toe of the foot bruise on Vandelay
Silva man. That was the first fight.
Famous footprint.
Yeah.
That was back when Vandelay and him had
that weird rules where they only find
the ground for 30 seconds.
They just wanted to stand in
bludgeon each other. Well,
there was a, it was first time
that cro cop had fought MMA. Yeah.
Weird hybrid match. He wanted some weird
rules and if it, if nothing happened,
if nobody finished anybody
who was a draw. Yeah. Yeah.
So that's how that fight turned out
a draw. And then in the rematch,
he just beat the career out of it
and the rematch, it was full cro cop.
There's the, there's the uh, photo
right there. There's the picture.
Look at that picture.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
The photo of Marco's fucking Chin
halfway into heath herrings body is so
terrifying. It's wrapping around.
That's a perfect kick. I, so can you,
can you kick any better than that?
That's about it. It's perfect.
And here Jeremy and cub going
at it in the third round.
Jeremy cannot wait for
this round to be over.
This is amazing fight so far
though. Yeah, it is. Well,
good knee to the body by cub.
Okay.
Do you think everyone always says hey.
Oh Hey, there's that Mexican actor. Ooh,
Mexican actor.
Oh, that guy. I didn't see that
movie, but I know who that guy is.
I've seen him in other shit.
Let me hear what they're saying.
Give us some volume,
Jamie
to work. They're like, attacks are good.
I need combinations. Two to three punches.
There's talking about combination.
I want to know about his Bonnie
deep breath here. It is slanted. Yeah.
Right to the liver man
that look on your face when you know
it's coming and he can't stop it.
Is that right hand over the top?
Look how accurate cub is. Yup.
He's so fucking accurate
in these wild malaise.
Okay.
It was one of the most impressive
things I've ever seen as far as like
combinations of techniques landed was
his fight with Seaver. Yeah, it was.
Yeah cause it was, everything was bunched
up in one certain fucking box. Yeah.
And he was, there were, you know,
Siva was moving away and he was chasing
after him was still catching with
everything. Here's a good kick by cub cubs
coming on strong and that third round.
This is a very interesting fight.
Now round two definitely.
You got to give to Jeremy Stevens.
Round three definitely got to give to cub
the first round. I think Steven's one.
But you put your, you're heading
into subjective in competence area.
You know when a fight is close it's
like you would like experts to call it,
but they're not. That's the weirdest
thing about MMA judging. It's,
they're not experts at all. Some lady that
got the job because she knew somebody.
Then the question,
I mean for,
for people who don't know anything
about MMA that are listening to this,
you would think they were exaggerating,
but we're, we're not exaggerating.
MMA judging is the worst out of any sport
in the world that you could think of
where you have like experts that are
watching the contest at the highest level
and they're, they're aware of the subtle
nuances of ebb and flow. The fight world.
Well, that must be the
case in MMA, surely,
where there's billions
of dollars on the line.
Multinational corporations owned by Viacom
and people called zoo fa and by they
would ensure that these
headings or someone else's
life judged correctly. Cool.
Courier. No, they're
just fucking terribly,
they're the worst judged contests probably
in all of professional sports is MMA.
There's more in competence in a MMA
judging and more judging being done by
people who have no idea what
they're watching. Just guesswork.
We'll have no background in the sport, no
background, not even as an amateur, not,
not as an amateur competitor,
not even as a person who practices
it and not even a martial artist.
No martial arts background at all.
Okay.
A lot of the delays,
sometimes we'll get on when there's a bad
decision and there's, there's a delay.
A lot of times our ring announcer,
Michael C.
Williams is going around making sure
that they knew it was the right person.
Like you know they're the one with the
gray shorts and then the want the red
shorts. Right. We had one where they had
mixed it up, dad gone the wrong person.
He had to go around and go, uh, you know
they have the retro, it's like Oh hold on.
And they scratched it and put different,
different numbers in there.
It has happened man
and competence.
It's just the sport was kind of like
nudged in and one of the Wa the big pieces
of evidence that it was nudged in is the
adoption of the 10 point must system.
It's just not a good system. It was
too much going on in MMA and boxing.
That system makes sense
cause you're only boxing.
But when you have boxing
with knees, elbows, kicks,
and then take downs and then
submissions and then ground impound,
all those variables that don't exist in,
in a boxing scoring system, it's just
the 10 points. It's just not enough.
What does it do? Like a 30 point
system. That's a good idea.
Groundwork takedowns and then strike it.
And it's still all subjective though.
You'd have to know what the fuck is
going on. Like you'd have to know,
like sometimes the guys caught in
a, in a guy's, uh, like a guy got,
has a guy's nice and a lot of trouble
and sometimes the guys not in trouble at
all.
And you have to be able to differentiate
between a guy who's defending really
well and a guy who's not
defending well at all.
It was on the brink of getting finished
at any second. There's a difference.
Well, cubs smiling because he defended
a takedown. Good. He punched the body.
They're in short range.
He's taking that right hand at the body.
How, how hard are those knees
to the thigh on the Europe,
the hero of the cage like that? How much
of those suck? I don't, I don't know.
Do you know, feel him at the time? No. I
mean, you're so amped up with adrenaline.
Yeah. And you just kind of get
past the pain thing. That's just,
that's going to go away. Or when
you're in training, do you wear,
do you wear knee pads when
you're in training, when you
do those? Sometimes, yeah.
I won't need without any pads on.
I mean that's just not really fair.
They can fuck each other up is
rude. Yeah, exactly. It's just some,
some rude shit to do to each other.
It's like foot stomps and training.
You have to be an asshole. It's fucking
stupid. Front knee kicks. Oh yeah.
Those are brutal.
Those little bleak kicks in front,
like so kicks at Jon Jones does to the
PSI effective, but they're an old cub.
Just Nice. He's blitzkrieg ing. Jeremy's
starting to slow down a little bit.
I noticed a number of training where
I got kicked a need around the muscle.
When they find that space
in between the muscles.
Ooh. Oh Man. It was always
terrible the next day.
That's the accuracy of real Thai baht.
Real Thai guys at one spot and
the kick it twice and you're like,
fuck 'em I'm sucks over this.
Vanessa,
who's used to always get that spot right
above the knee where the bone meets the
top of the quad or the
bottom on the quad stopped.
He googled Changin with kicks and K one.
Yeah,
there's a few of those guys that tried
to venture forth in the k one from MMA
work. Tourists results,
oftentimes disastrous results.
But rampage did that.
A lot of people forget.
Rampage fought Mike Bernardo and beat
them and beat them in fucking k one
rampage was a beast in his prime.
I mean, it's Kinda sucks now here,
and I'm talking about retirement and
Hayden and yeah, he's still fighting,
but you could tell he's kind of on his
way out doing it for the money. Yeah.
Job Security. Yeah. Well it's a lot of
money. Me, he's got a bunch of kids too.
There's a lot going on.
You got to keep that money coming in.
It's, but it's, it's one of those guys,
he was the first guy ever rolled
with ever wrap on a mat was rampage.
I'm actually, that was fun. Yeah.
Um, he brings it up a lot when,
when we're hanging out and every time I
see him and, uh, uh, nice. Look at that.
Nice. Neat. Naturally when
the most incredibly strong
people. Yeah. He's so strong.
My God.
Yeah.
I rolled with him before when
we were filming that a UFC,
whatever the fuck it was show for
spike. Yeah. So strong. It's ridiculous.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Final round here. Hey, that last
round one to, it's a good question.
That's a close one.
It was close.
Okay.
I wasn't really paying attention enough
to score it. You know, I don't like,
I mean sometimes a rounds obvious,
but even when I'm doing commentary,
I don't know because what
I'm doing commentary,
I'm trying to point out all
these different things about,
around and I'm not doing it.
I think if you're going to score around,
you should shut the fuck up and you should
have a piece of paper in front of you
and you should be marking things down.
You know,
Eddie Bravo used to do
it in between fights. Um,
in between rounds he would talk
about the round and you know,
I'd have like an official scorekeeper,
like a,
they have Harold Harold betterment for
the u s or for a boxing and Eddie used to
have two columns,
one for each guy and he would have all
these marks down as far as like hard
kicks that were landed punches that were
landed near submissions and he had a
whole system that he would do and
it was a very accurate system.
I agreed with every one of his little,
a little in fight inbetween round things,
creativity,
being smart and being knowledgeable
of what the fuck's going on. Control.
There's a lot of variables.
I just think that there,
there's too many variables
for a 10 point must system.
We need our own system and I don't,
I don't know what the hell is going to be.
I would like them to Kipp come up with
better fucking gloves and I would like
them to come up with a better
scoring system. Those are
my two number one gripes.
I have to score mine for belts or,
and I have some,
some fighters to get pissed
at me, man. Yeah. Sorry Dude.
Why did they make you it is dead. It's
always a good idea. And I was like,
all right, I don't mind doing it. You
know, you should probably tell them, well,
I don't know,
do whatever the fuck you want.
But I would probably tell them
I don't want to do that anymore.
I don't mind doing it. Just, you know,
just who I think won and why and you know,
it's just a good template for
right. Here's why. I think in,
in explaining the scorecard,
it does make me break it down what I'm
thinking while I'm watching it. Right.
So I do like it. Do you write
things down when you're scoring?
Like when you were doing commentary,
do you write anything down? Yeah. Yeah.
Sometimes I do. Most of the time
I do. Yeah. I, I just try to,
when I'm doing commentary, since I don't
have to score, I just try to be, oh
damn. He's hitting them
hard with that left. Oh,
another right hand is on
a man. Oh, cartwheel kick.
Beautiful Double Jab. Look at
them. Hands Down right hand. Oh,
he's taken over.
Jeremy's a bloody mess too.
He's so creative. Like look what he
just did there. He ducks down wings,
that overhead.
Old Left Hook.
So every time he's so accurate man.
And Punch in with your head off of the,
you know the beeline punch in the same
area and still have you and have your
head off of, you know, whatever line
you're going on. The other lead. Right?
Two minutes ago though. Good combinations.
This, this round is still kicking.
Jeremy's got a lot of blood coming out
of that nose. Oh, splattering everywhere.
Yeah. His face is a mess. Oh,
come throws a lot of off speed stuff too.
He does things.
He's really hard to figure out
what he's going to do. Yeah.
Okay.
Very sneaky with the way he moves at
you hit like slow, slow, fast. You know,
he does a lot of that nice left
hook there and it's hard to see.
It's a lot of times it's hard to see
punches it come from the hip like that.
Yeah. Very difficult. Especially,
we have good head movement and
he's got very good movement.
Very good waste movement back and forth.
Okay.
Damn. Yeah, I'm happy I don't have to
score this fucking thing. I really,
I just get to watch it and I have to worry
about it. Well, I just don't know man.
I just, I think if I was going to
score around and do, do my best at it,
I really would shut the fuck
up. Yeah, you'd have to. Yeah.
Which I'm sure some people would like.
I cannot, I've got to talking and score.
It's nice left hook again by carb.
This is all cub this round. Yeah,
totally. Jeremy's got to know that.
I mean this is a,
it's a very interesting situation.
I think you all my hinge on that
fourth round was real close.
Yeah. Right. Cause three
and five are definitely cub.
I would say one and two
are Stephen's right now.
Well this is all that fourth
round just looked up at the clock.
This is a perfect example of why one brown
being a ten nine and this round being
a ten nine is ridiculous. Yeah. So
the round that was really close,
if that was a ten nine for
either one of those guys.
And then this is a ten nine round for cub.
That's fucking crazy.
That highlights how fucked up the system
is because carb is schooling him in
this round and Cobb also schooled
him and that other route. Oh,
Jeremy Lands that right
hand. Woo. Still dangerous.
It's still dangerous. Fucking 24
minutes. 24 and a half minutes in.
Yup. Yeah. Good one. Yeah.
He carries her fucking power.
He'll switch it up to get you thinking
about that overhand and come with that
upper gut. Oh, we, y'all heard
him? He heard him. Who was
a stumble there, man. Damn.
Jeremy Stevens is swinging a hate
to see somebody lose a fight. Man.
That's a great fight. Wow.
Holy Shit. She's a great fight.
Look at these guys. Awesome. Fantastic
fight. I love this too. I love this.
I love these guys walking around, holding
each others arms up. Yeah, amazing.
Especially have to fight. And there was
a moment of pause when the bell rang.
We were still like, fuck you. Ah, goodbye.
Because Jerry was chasing after a moving
in for the kill and that last minute.
Wow. Amazing fight. I still
gave that last round to cub,
but that highlights why, you
know, it's like, what is that?
Is that a ten nine round?
Is that a ten eight what is it?
Ten eight you know what the fuck?
Why do we still have this 10 point system?
It's fucking goofy.
So what do you think you have
to judge if you had to guess.
I think cub did more damage. I would
say cub. Yeah. I would say to Cobb as,
I mean the problem is when you're looking
at that whole 10 point must system is,
is it going to be looked
like that at the judges?
So it's same right now that that Jeremy
broke his hand. Is that what they said?
That's what it says right
now. Dana White tweeted, oh,
he broke his hand and the
third round when or which hand?
I was thrown both there at the end. So
I was, I was trying to pay attention.
He's so crazy. He probably didn't bother
him at all. It goes numb. Yeah. Yeah.
You don't want to feel it. He probably
knew it and just kept bombing with it.
I fuck,
I mean I,
I crushed my hand and broke my knuckle
and like five pay up pieces and then
broke my hand too. Impacted it
and it just, you don't feel it.
I mean it's not like I'm like fuck
yeah, propane, you know, it's,
he just went numb and I think I,
you know,
I threw a hundred and punches in the
makeup show that fist make a fist.
That's where it goes. A little
bridge right now. What's a little,
a little swollen credit.
I can land it in his fucking eye socket.
And when you're training,
what do you,
what do you do to me your hands
different with Boston gloves on it, it's,
it's the padding's there
so it helps out a lot.
But if I still put it in someone's
forehead or something or catch it on an
overhand, which is how I broke it. A,
it fucking hurts my fingers going
to break like this. I mean it's,
it's all fucking bruise right now, but
you know, it's all right. Like it is here.
It is.
Okay.
Cub Swanson. I thought it was just
fun. Yeah, I think that's justified.
I think it's justified in terms
of the overall fight. Yeah.
If you look at the overall fight, I think
that cub Swanson one, the overall fight,
definitely.
Jeremy had some moments in definitely
Jeremy scored a lot and had cub heard at
one point in time,
but
it's a good fight, man. Yeah,
really good. Yeah, that's,
that's the kind of fight that you want
to see when you see a guy who's fighting
for a world title next.
Yeah.
He fights another top guy in the division
to hungry young lions and both guys
had moments. You know, Jeremy had
some big moments in that fight,
but Cobb had more moments. It's
a big win for him, man. Yes. And
Jeremy Stevens being now
the harder hitter. He,
he stepped forward and
landed some good shots.
Cub had to do a lot of things
to keep that pressure on.
He didn't have that one shot power.
You had to show a lot of accuracy
through a lot of jabs mixed.
A lot of kicks in there.
A lot of head movement.
He had to do a lot more cause
he didn't have that power. Yeah.
That's an interesting, I like seeing
that person. Yeah, I do too. Well that's,
that's a kind of fight to,
that makes a guy really grow.
That's some serious fucking experience
you get there mentally. Just,
just your fight Iq goes up
fucking a lot of points.
When you fought like w who's,
who do you think is he?
See Ian Mccall when you
fought mighty mouse,
when you fought Benevidez what fight?
Do you have any fights
that you look back on?
He say that's the fight that
really I took the most from.
Ah,
I would say it'd be in Joe.
I don't think either of us fought to our
full potential and that fight. How come?
I don't know. We just kinda
stood there. We didn't really,
neither of us move like we should have
it didn't get after it, you know? Um,
you know, I'm pretty disappointed my UFC
career, so I don't know. Are you willing?
Yeah, no. Dude, you are a perfectionist.
Striving to improve. Yeah. I should be
world champion. That's not good enough.
And I think that I, everyone knows
I'm the only threat to Demetrius.
Listen to you and you know it's I
fucking molester than once on the ground.
I'll do it again and get my fucking
hands on you. I'm gonna, I'm gonna.
I think that, you know what? I
don't have the best pair of Jujitsu.
I don't have the best pure wrestling.
I don't have the best pure striking,
but when it comes to getting in a fucking
fist fight and having it end up on the
ground,
I'll fuck up anybody in my weight class.
I don't think there's anybody who
can do it. Want to scramble with me.
You want to, you know,
with, with submissions and
shit like that and punches.
I'll fuck you up. What do you think
separates you? What do you think it is?
Okay.
Oh Man. I don't want to sound
like gene the bell too much,
but I do the belt and I get off
on it. You know, it's, it's,
and it's maybe not as sexual as
Jean Jean likes it to be, but I,
I thoroughly enjoy fucking people up,
man.
It's always entertaining. I got a lot of
pent up aggression. I like to perform.
I think performing's become
the biggest part. Just putting
on a show. Yeah. And if,
if someone's, you know, their wellbeing
is at stake during that. I'm fuck,
I'm sorry. Sorry. I'm not sorry.
And what car do you on next? Uh,
July 19th and Ireland. I'm fighting
Brad Pickett finally. Finally fight.
That's how you get your site in
English, man. And I am in the name. Wow.
I have a super gets, well, it's
Gaelic, it's uh, you know, it's Irish,
Scottish whales. I think it's a
Gaelic is oh, your last name. Yeah,
it's and we'll call you don't get
any more Irish than that, but sorry,
I'm not Irish. Yeah, they're going to
be bummed out. Like put the fuck man.
You confusing us. We want to route
Irish and Mexican or something.
That's Hilarious, man. That's a good
fight though. I love that fight.
Brad pickets fun. He's a fun guy.
He's, I mean we're, we're gonna,
we're gonna get a bonus.
Did picket fight flyway yet?
Once it would be fine. Neil Neil, Siri,
the Irish guy. Did he win or lose?
He won but he looked like shit. Did
he? Yeah, I mean he tough weight cut.
I think that's what was a big part of it.
And you know you're supposed to be a
boxer and you get cracked and you'll turn
into a wrestler, but I'm not going
to get a Russell by an Englishman.
Embarrassing.
But I talk shit.
But I got fucking taken down
by a Brazilian so I've, I
jumped into it. But again,
I say stupid shit all the time. You're
comfortable with saying stupid shit. Yeah,
because it's entertainment,
you know,
I think people get buttered on Twitter
that should I say and I'm like,
motherfucker, you got a problem,
you can text me or something.
I have some people that
I know have gotten hurt.
The Internet is filled with people that
are not just bought her Lukey and to be
butt hurt and I'm just playing the game.
People have said the most horrible
shit to me online. I mean with,
with recent events, especially shit
that had been said to me, I'm like,
Jesus Christ, you guys are mean
because they don't going to feelings.
If I had a heart. Yeah. And this would
really suck. Not just mean, but mean.
And they don't even know you. Like,
it's not like they're angry at you.
They're trying to get back because you
did something to them that they can't
forgive. It's like, no, you don't have
any relationship with them at all.
They just reach out to you and just
try to shit on you because the life is
fucking misery ever met before
because now you're saying some shit.
If you were in person,
I'd break this fucking Mug over
your head and stick it in the neck.
You want to fuck me? I mean
like what? What for what reason?
Just to try to get just a rise
out of you to ruin my day. Well,
it's because response from you because
they don't have anything going on in
their lives. Gotcha. Rogan mad
and he said something to me,
it's a big deal to them.
This is definitely true
that that's, that's a fact.
And that's a sure sign that you're a loser
because that's something that winners
don't do. I've always said that Michael
Jordan is not leaving youtube comments.
No. You know, he's not like shitting
all over someone who's fucking video.
You know what I mean? It's fucking song
blows scope. The dining a fire, you know,
that kind of attitude is almost always
perpetrated by losers and it's just a
matter of thinking a certain way that
you will constantly chase down an Ian
Mccall and shit all over.
I'm gonna try to hurt us feel and try to
try to reach them online and try to eat,
recognize me
fucking scene.
The Guy,
he's a fucking supposed to be a comedian
and he called that Louis C K for a
fight to fight Louie who? Some
fucking guy, I don't know his name,
I don't fight Louis C K wants to fight
him. And he called out me and he says,
check this guy out, calling out
Louis C K and I was like, oh.
So I retweeted it and then I watched
it and I was like, is that you?
You're a fucking douchebag.
Horrible piece of shit.
And I'm sorry I fucking retweeted that.
But like you're the kind of guy that
I'm going to fucking spit in my hand and
slap you in the mouth with it.
Like so he's calling out Louis C K
because Lucy Kay is doing well. Exactly.
And then he calls me out.
Oh who the fuck you're talking to?
Like
weird.
And there's a lot of idiots out there but
those idiots think that that's the way
they can become famous.
That's the way they can get a
name, you know, credit card.
And he used to do the MMA uncensored
show. He's all right. He is.
Everybody hates the guy cause it's his,
he's like a New York loud mouth like
radio hosts and everybody hates him.
And we were doing a shoot.
I was on the show and he's actually
a nice guy in real life and he goes,
not one time with all the hate I get.
Has anyone in real life in person ever
said anything to me? I go, really?
He goes not once,
and he is hated.
Not like there's some people out
there that don't like you and me, Joe,
I'm talking like most people don't
like crit carton. He's liking them.
Noxious and they don't.
Most people I've talked to a
litter MMA fans like you a lot. Oh,
I think you do really well.
But yeah,
there are some people that
just get fucking universally,
there's some people I talked to a lot
of people that fucking hate Jon Jones,
you know, they're talking to me
about how John Jones is hated.
All my friends hate Jon Jones. He's
so fucking cocky. And I'm like,
let me help you out here. Here's
what's going on. You know?
And I know that Jon Jones is awesome
and that's one of the things that's
bothering you. Is it? Jon
Jones knows he's awesome.
Does he do things that are debatable?
Yeah,
he got in an accident with a Bentley
when he was drunk with a bunch of strip,
presume his car.
Me like he was having a
good time and have a night.
You can't get a lot of us in that.
So what are you mad at?
You mad at the fact that he thinks
he's going to win every fight.
Guess why he won every fight. So he's
driving, you know like what do you matter?
I don't understand that. You mad
that he's, he's ducking Gustafson.
He wanted to fight Daniel fucking
core me a Olympic wrestler.
Undefeated both as a heavyweight
and as a light heavyweight.
A guy who's been running through
people destroyed Dan Henderson.
He wants to fight him and you
think he's a coward. Yeah,
that makes a lot of sense. People
are fucking stupid. Look the simple,
the simple phrase of go ahead and
explain yourself. Yeah. Tiers.
Most people completely of, no, just tick
that tick. Tick that logic a bit further.
I just want to, I just want to hear
you express it. One piece at a time.
All said everything falls apart.
The other thing that fucks people up is
the platform of being able to do like a
Twitter post or a blog entry or you know
anything where you're not addressing
the human.
A person's not challenging what Cannibal.
Like if you're saying something,
even if you're saying something to me,
if you're not talking to Jon Jones,
you're saying something to me that doesn't
make any sense. I'll go, wait, hold on.
What? I'll stop you if the first
paragraph and go, that's not even true.
That doesn't make sense.
Well here's why.
But instead they get to just buy through
a whole entire blog entry and justify
their thoughts or what
unchecked and by the end of it,
you know somebody reads it,
they'll get angry,
they'll have all these opinions on it,
but it would have never happened
if they were interactive.
There was an experiment at Stanford
University where they put people in masks
and had them shock people and that is
that a control group or one subject didn't
have masks on and they were behind this
glass and they were shocking people.
When they would answer a question,
question certain way,
then they took a group of will and put
masks on them and did the same experiment
and people would hit the button
like incessantly. When there was,
they wouldn't even ask a question.
They would just shock them.
As soon as they became anonymous,
they will hit that fucking thing when
they said the right answer when they
didn't even talk in and they
realize when you make people,
and this is like 1972 and they realize
when you make people anonymous,
they will do horrible shit
incessantly and well Susie,
what mask on?
They would hit the shock button
constantly throughout the experiment.
Why do you think the KKK wore masks?
People are shitty.
People can be under the flushing
shitty but also awesome. You know,
people are pretty fucking awesome. I all,
my favorite people are people. The way,
the way I look at it personally,
that's, that's a great statement.
The way my favorite people or
animals and throwing that out there.
I know I like pets and shit.
I'm going to monkeys and shit.
My as monkeys do have shit and they
do have shit and they fling it.
My thing is like I like,
you know,
if I like something I'm a,
I'm a reasonable normal human being and
I don't like pickles and I liked the
Pittsburgh Steelers.
I've never gone online and talked
about either one of those subjects.
Most people didn't like something or
don't want to just go, oh yeah. I'm like,
you know,
Jimmy Smith is all right.
They're not going to get on
a form and yell about me.
It's the vast majority people that likes
something and just enjoy it generally
don't make a big deal,
but we're talking about very slender part
of the population that it's just loud,
obnoxious about stuff. Yeah.
No matter what you know,
no matter what you do in the smart phone,
right.
Every asshole has a fucking voice.
Now.
Everybody's going to pin this
thing about being anonymous. I must
be able to reach people. This is
unprecedented in human culture. Yeah.
It's never happened before, so people
don't know how to fucking deal with it.
They don't know how to manage it.
It's just,
it's not a ability that
anybody's ever had in history.
So this ability is something that it's
going to take a long time for people to
manage and use and I think what's going
to change it more than anything is it's
somewhere along the line we're
going to lose it. Not anonymity.
I think everyone's going to
know who everyone else is.
You're going to be accountable
at the NSA. Yeah, it's gonna.
It's exactly like if you were doing
death threats to the government,
they know who you are immediately.
You could try to hide behind a proxy,
but if you're,
they're going to find you,
they're going to find you really quickly
and ultimately that kind of ability is
going to trickle down to the common man.
Everyone's going to have that.
Yeah you do.
And the world is going to know that
you're a cunt for doing that too.
Have you found out like you remember
that reddit thing that happened a while
back where there was a guy who would post
all kinds of fucked up shit on reddit
and he like like creep shots,
like up skirt shots and stuff and underage
shots and all these different weird
creepy shit.
And then they found out who he was in
real life and they contacted his employer
and showed him all the
stuff that he put on line.
They fire that fucking guy could well
and the guy had like a wife and kids and
the whole deal and you know like lost
his job and he got outed on the Internet
and you know, millions of people
hated that guy after that. So many
people got ahold of the articles and
retweeted things and Facebook didn't.
It was a big issue,
a big issue about freedom of speech
and privacy but also a big issue about
outing fuckheads. Yeah.
Good. Fuck them. Yup. Yeah.
Fuck them all. Fuck them all
says Ian Mccall. Rimes and rimes.
Really well. So a, the
fights are over gentlemen.
I guess the podcast is over to this
has been a great time. Yes, this is,
it hasn't been fucking fun. Three hours.
We put this together this afternoon too.
Yeah, I got a call this afternoon
we doing tonight. Nothing Bro.
What's going on and was like,
I am there. I am there. Yeah.
This is a lot of work on my seat,
man.
I'll be there and I really wanted to do
with you too because I mean I don't know
how many people know that we were really
friendly with each other. You know,
despite the fact that we're supposed to
be something we're supposed to knock,
I guess we're supposed to be rivals.
There's some shit are not going along
with the whole Bjorn Dana thing.
That's so goofy to me. It's what, you
know when you, when I was talking to,
I mean the way I see it is if
there's a rivalry in UFC, in Beltour,
at what level does that really happen?
Like when I see Kenny are you, it's like,
hey, what's like we're peers,
we do the same job. We like,
hey, how's it going man?
We talked about fire to
whatever and you know,
I know you know a lot of the technical
people that have worked on both shows and
like they don't get along.
It's not the director sees my director
and starts a fight or something like fuck
you. Yeah. Does my work that way. It's
really good. You know? It's funny,
I ran into some dude's last, a small
like foster man. I love that guy. Yeah,
great guy. He's a great
guy. My boy, I love him.
I ran into some guys last night that it
just Jujitsu guys and we talked to Jitsu
till two o'clock in the fucking morning.
That's like when you run into someone
who likes what you like and you start
talking like, I mean I don't
understand. I don't know.
I've never understood that though.
I've supported the people's podcasts,
I've always supported other comedians.
I just, I don't, I don't see that.
I think the main competition is always
with yourself and when you bring in
someone else who's good or
you have someone around you
that's good and you have
to compare yourself to them,
I think it makes you better.
So I think it's important. Every
true, you see that a lot in MMA man.
How many times you see
guys that are training,
they're in the same God damn
weight class and they're,
they're helping each other out and you
know that one day they might have to
fight like your riot and
t and Tj Dillashaw after
Uriah loses to hand Barao he
says, Hey, you know
there's a guy in my camp,
I'd love to see him fight for the title
next. I love to see him. See Tj Dillashaw.
I get a shot.
Same fucking way class beating
each other's asses every
day and still supporting
him. That's the fucking,
that's a brotherhood right
there. That's where it's at,
right?
That's where it's not that big.
I think that's what people don't get
is community is not that big. No.
We all know one another.
At least.
There's like two degrees of separation
in this entire sport. Maybe.
How many of us are they? Not at, not
a lot of us out there. Jason Chambers,
who's a friend of mine who does a one FC.
Yep.
There's you who Smith who
I fought Jason Chambers.
Like it's just like there's only
one degree of separation. This tire.
You guys both had a TV show where you're
traveling around and doing different
martial arts. He did human weapon. I
didn't fight quest. He keep called me.
Send me a message. As soon as Fike
was came out and goes, hey man, great.
See on TV man, hope we get to the
to hang out soon. I was like, Hey,
good luck with your thing too bro. And
like Jason's, it's like what we're,
you know, we're gonna you know Jason,
he's right over again. We already did one.
It's ridiculous. It
doesn't work that way. No.
You know Anthony Bourdain
and Andrew Zimmerman, he had,
I'm going to like to have a brawl
traveling. I mean, how many
of us are there? There's now,
there's a couple of
fighters would do at Kenney.
Brian Stand and Frank Mir
used to do it until what?
He said he wanted to kill
Brock Lesnar in the ring,
one of the houses to be the first
MMA death in ring. Not Smart.
Well not the smart, but still. I
don't think it's like, you know,
the guy's a great commentator who's nearly
good. Yeah. I enjoyed his commentary,
but I mean there's only the point
being this may be 10 of us worldwide.
I mean, I don't know who
does that Indian promotion.
They still have that Indian promotion
superfly league or something.
I know there's one bag for a little while.
The Arab Emirates you at Uva,
UAE. Um, one of my buddies
is fighting out there soon.
Is that a new organization?
I think so.
You know how much money
they have to think of.
It's hard to think of any job or
they're a few fewer people doing it,
then it would make commentary. There
are a dozen of us in the whole world.
Like how many jobs are there? Yeah,
there they're 10 of us. Yeah, no shit.
[inaudible] CEO, there's, you
know, several hundred. Yeah. Yeah.
That was why we can run an inch with
her into each other and talk shit,
talk shop rather just what we do general.
Yeah. How many of us are this is,
that's it. That's interesting. Yeah.
That's probably as far as others,
like the two major promotions
that anyone has seen,
president of the United
States is probably, you know,
that's a singular biggie.
It's a biggie when you run into
former presidents, you're fucking but,
but there's a former presidents as far
as people doing the job currently, man.
Yeah, I guess boxing commentators,
but there's probably way more of them.
More boxing on TV too.
Well they always do more guys to,
like I was listening to some
boxing last night and it was like,
which I don't like in MMA. Yeah, but they
do them in boxing. Well it can fuck up.
Especially if you know you got too many
people talking over each other when
action happens or they don't like specific
roles like especially when it comes
to,
I think you and I both do something very
different than other sports too where
there's a color guy and a play by play,
but we both do play by play. We do color,
but we also do play by play,
especially when shit goes to the ground
because the play by play guy doesn't
really know what the fuck is happening.
What they do a little,
but you kind of have to do that.
Well,
you have to explain every nuance of the
position and then start to explain what
could be bad if this happens.
And what could be good if that happens.
Or women amaze the color medium.
I,
it's Jeff Blatnick who I love,
Love Jeff Blatnick. He was,
I thought it was a great, as a rescue
is a great, great human being. Um,
when he started doing color
commentary for the UFC,
it became a color medium just
because if you, if you watch boxing,
my mom knows what's happening in boxing
match you d I mean they would ask
Emmanuel steward little stuff and,
or you know,
it was George Foreman for awhile at
Hbo and, but the play by play guy,
that's the voice of Hbo is
Jim Lampley Basically, um,
with MMA color,
guys have to talk a lot more because
there's a lot more of the audience doesn't
know the answer is never done Jujitsu.
The answer has never done Muay Thai.
The audience knows boxing a little bit.
They'd never wrestled.
So there's so many facets that the fans
have just never been a part of that.
We have to break down and
explain and I think it's made it,
the color guys have to do a lot
more than them. It made them,
they do in boxing a lot more. Yeah, more.
It's a completely different gig
and that's also, it's also a,
a gig that would be really cumbersome
with a bunch of people talking if you had
like three or four people in the booth.
We've done three in the UFC before,
but it didn't work that well.
And Dana didn't like it and so they
went back to two. Yeah, it's brief.
The Times I've done it in Beltsville,
they'll have like somebody jumped
in for around it too. Yeah.
I think what would be,
yeah,
I think we'll be cool as a guy doing
the Harold Letterman Gig though,
that Eddie Bravo used to do. Yeah.
You know, Eddie's too busy these days.
He wouldn't do it. But someone who's
like a real experienced guy, like uh,
you know,
that would be a good thing to do.
Like to have like a
dominant Cruz or you know,
someone along that lines who's
really good at breaking things down.
It's very analytical.
Give some,
I think it would help give people some
insight and also give some insight as to
really what's wrong with the scoring.
We could see if you've got a real
expert at breaks down exactly what they
thought about each individual aspect of
the fight and then you see in contrast
how shitty the the judges
perceptions of the fight where, yeah,
I'd probably say sign me up
and I'd probably say some stuff
[inaudible] shit.
Well,
you know what I've liked and elected
Josh Barnett has a blog now or has a
podcast now. I think, you know, you'd be
great at something like that too, man.
We've thought about it. I've had a
few people kind of hit me up about it.
We have a business called a direct
endorsement where we do live streaming for
only for an hour and we take an athlete,
not just fighting, but fighting,
skateboarding, motorcross, whatever it is.
They pick a charity, we pick a product,
say it's this Mug,
everyone buys the mug. We,
as we're doing that through
the, you know, the, the,
the podcast that person's signing
while we're talking, asking questions,
we get into what the charity is
and it's just, it's, you know,
like whatever percentage they want.
Usually 20% goes to the, the, uh,
the charity they pick. So that's very
cool. It's a cool little thing we had,
we only had three of them. We
did myself. We did a quick,
let's go for skateboarding and Kyle Loza
for motocross and we'd like to get on
the ball and start doing more. Might you
Donal Logue for acting and just some,
you know,
just to kind of,
just to hit different surfaces
just because I don't have,
I don't really hang out
with fighters that much.
Yeah, no, that's interesting. So what,
you only hung out with fighters from
your training when you get outside of
training?
Yeah, I mean, realistically I'm the
hanging out people at the gym. If I'm not,
not at the gym,
I'm at home with my kid.
But a lot of people that are fighters
find that they're the only people that
understand them, that other fighters
like it's such a crazy lifestyle
to the training. So brutal. The,
it's almost like you need someone to
commiserate with or you need someone who
understands what you're going through.
You don't feel like that. Um, I do,
but I don't want to talk about it.
I want to just fucking forget about it.
I want to hang out with my,
you know,
with my kid and my girlfriend and her
kid and just not have to worry about the
fucking misery that I put myself through
for, for, for greatness. You know, it's,
it's a lot of fun. I love
my job. Don't get me wrong,
but I'd usually don't want
to talk about it, you know,
unless it's on something like this. So
you're, you preserve your interest in it.
Yeah, because otherwise, you know, I do.
I've been watching more fights
lately now that I, you know,
meet me and my dad lived together.
That's a fucking all he does.
And my daughter loves watching fights.
That's hilarious.
A two and a half year old, loves watching
fights and she now, you know, she sees,
you know, uncle Shane's on the TV, you
know, this person's on the TV, this Romy,
there's, you know, coach or whatever.
It is cute. That is cute. Um, when you,
when you're in between camps,
like say like after a fight and you,
you don't have anything
scheduled for a while,
how much time do you spend training and
working on things and how much is just,
just decompressing?
I live a very active lifestyle.
Like everything I do is outdoors.
You know, I'm in Tahoe, Reno a lot,
high altitude, so we're always going on
hikes and I'm always doing, you know,
high altitude beaker and with
my girlfriend and w we just,
she doesn't let me fucking sit still.
Like she always has something to do with
the kids are with me and her or fucking
it. We've even for traveling, like
went to Costa Rica for a surf trip.
So we served him at jungle hiking and
tried to find fucking Sloss and monkeys
and shit. I know. So it's
like, if she keeps, it keeps
my attention going and, and I,
I'm always fit. That's cool.
That's a cool vacation. Yeah.
Except for the diseases and the bugs
that can kill you. See any of those.
Everything wants to kill you down. Yeah.
I mean, it's not like you got to Hawaii.
Like I went to Hilo and hung
out with Bj and we went to Ypo.
I'm looking around like,
where's your bugs? Yeah, well
there's fucking mosquitoes.
But besides that, I'm like, there's
nothing here that wants to kill me.
Even the mosquitoes I
think came from people.
They brought him over on boats and
shit. He's like, no bro, he's cool. No,
we're just going to hang out. And if, you
know, farm some farms from Taro. Okay.
Bj has been there his whole life and still
trains there. That's crazy. Yeah. We, we,
we finished building the gym in Ypo,
his little Dojo,
I call it my Miyagi. And, uh, and then one
morning I woke up, I was like, hey bro,
I'm gonna go want to go bust the gym.
Like, yeah, it's a great, grab your shit.
Let's go. And we just fucking drove
the Ypo and it's got a sh, you know,
little shitty old truck it doesn't care
about and drives it through the river
and it's got no, no, no. Uh, no electrical
has been shorted so it's no, no, uh,
no radio or anything.
He just drives through the most
fucking beautiful country you can.
And then we go in there and we just beat
the shit out of each other, you know,
half an hour.
We had some,
some shirtless fucking hippie
dude doing the time for us.
He used to like wrestle and high
school is, I'll stocking so we get,
can you just tell us when five
minutes is up? Okay. Ready? Go.
How many live in Hilo have no idea.
Not that, not that many, right.
It's like 30,000 or something crazy
because just the big island itself,
not a lot of people live in the big eye
on the big items. Fucking huge. Yeah.
I think the big island only has 100,000
people on it probably. And I mean it's,
it's, it's desolate. And
on the big island alone,
there's like every single climate in
the world except for like one or two.
It's, it's, it's, there's so much going
on there. It's so fucking beautiful.
You look and feel like you're in Jurassic
Park and especially getting to hang
out with him. It's, he's a fucking
savage man. It's a good time.
What do you think about this fight with
him and Frankie Edgar? He, like I said,
when I was out there, this is a while
ago, two months ago or something,
he was 160 pounds.
I got tired first and I don't,
I don't get fucking tired. I mean,
granted I just tore my hip and my groin,
but I still don't get tired much.
And he was,
I still stayed in shape and I mean,
he fucking,
he was going after me for
half an hour. Wow. And I was
just like, after I was like,
Oh, I'm fucking, I'm excited because he,
it's my favorite fighter of all time.
I mean, he's a fucking savage when you
can make another man cry, another man who,
who deserves a title shot at your title.
And you can beat him up so bad that he
cries and then you fucking lick his blood
off your gloves and bang your
head after I like, I like,
oh the Joe Stevenson place.
The problem is on throwing the counter
here is that he's always had trouble with
fights where he wasn't on top,
at least mentally.
When the ball starts rolling
the other way, it rolls bad.
The momentum goes the other way for him.
And so Eric is the guy you got to outwork
and that's as it always been physical
with Bj. It's when I'm not on
top and I'm not dominating,
when I'm not licking the
guy's blood off my hands,
I start questioning myself and I started
rolling backwards and if he's got those
mental demons in check, then he's got
a great shot. Yeah, it's the same.
Frankie Edgar always shows up and that's
saint consistent, so consistent, so hard.
Bj was so good when he's with the
Marinovich bitches when he fought Diego
Sanchez, he was in incredible shape.
He had a fucking full six pack.
I mean he was in shape and chasing
after Diego deep into the fight.
Fourth and fifth round going to hit
him twice, doesn't it? Open, open.
That was the only time Bj's ever
thrown a head kick in a fight.
Fucking landed perfect. Perfectly.
You know, I mean that was a,
that was him at his best because
he had tremendous stamina.
What do you know what he's doing now?
Oh,
for strength and
conditioning. I farming. Yeah.
What are, what are we doing? And
we're going to go farm manual labor.
I don't need fucking
strength conditioning.
We don't need strength and conditioning.
We just built roads in Ypo and fucking
Farm Taro and beat the shit out of each
other. Build the roads. We built like a
fucking, and like with like a unum og,
you know,
like Mercedes Union mugs,
you can put a fucking ditch
digger on the back and like,
I don't know what an [inaudible] is. A
big, uh, like a tractor kind of vehicle.
Big Mercedes unit. Mog All three of
them out there. And he has a farm. Yeah,
he's got a farm and you go into Ypo
valley and it's, there's, I mean,
not even a hundred people live there and
it's this huge fucking garden of Eden.
I mean it's massive and it's so
beautiful and just there nothing there.
Is he growing weed?
I wish I was he farming Tara.
Tara is Tara. If you say quietly into a
mic, they can still hear you should poops.
Makes no difference. Bring it
up. What is he was Taro? Taro is,
they're trying to make it to try and make
the Hawaiian superfood a Taro root and
it's, it's, it's a really starchy,
starchy vegetable that, you know,
that's why Hawaiians punched so
hard. That's what they tell me. Yeah.
My first fight was in Hawaii.
I had never heard a terrible before.
How about how have I never heard of this
before? It tastes like, like put like,
like bland is fuck and put sugar
in it and tastes like sugar.
But it's supposed to give you superpowers.
You know, it's, it's a matter before,
I don't remember where, but I've
had it before. What did you,
what's your impression of it? It's like
a, like a, like a more bland kind of Yam.
Yeah. This is the best way
to describe it, Huh? Yeah,
but it's super the soupy like [inaudible]
gooey. Huh? Weird. They mash it up.
I had it mashed up with something
that was like a Tarot kind of stew.
Is it supposed to be good for you?
Like actually like that's,
it's not supposed to be good for you.
It's fucking weird and purple.
That's a unit Mog oh, okay. So the,
the local Hawaii. Does anybody else?
He did. Is it anything
that like, you know,
everybody's eating like Bok
Choy now is the new Kale.
Everybody's telling you you got to
get ahold of some Bok Choy but he eats
[inaudible] in Hawaii.
But Dino Hawaiians are fucking,
they believe in like mermaids and shit.
Brother [inaudible]
and I love to death.
Don't get me wrong.
I love Hawaiians and like they're my
favorite fucking people on the planet.
Like that's the only place I vacation.
I lived with two fucking Hawaiians for,
you know, I live with Shane
and rich, rich who know rich.
He used to run Strikeforce.
He was mean match metric for Strikeforce
and they're both fucking Hawaiian.
And then I dunno,
I just really like fucking lines.
I tried vacation other the places. I'm
like, this isn't as good as Hawaiian.
Why am I fucking, I go
anywhere. Well Hawaii's right
there. It's going to Hawaii.
It's cheat. Well kind of. She is
still America but it's not, you know,
it's like you're protected by
the constitution to the alleged.
Go to Bj's and go to have him take you
to Ypo and you feel like you're in French
Polynesia or something
cause the people talking.
You're just like all meeting income goal
by some fees. You know, buckle around,
smoke some weed bro. High School. And
you're like, what did he just say?
Phrasebook that pigeon talking to Brian
and Bj starts rattling off stuff and
then you start drinking,
you know like homemade sock aid down
in the valley and then you just,
it just turns into it, I imagine
short food. Yeah. What plate lunches?
Manchild food. How am I supposed
to fucking make weight with this?
This is delicious, but it's not on
my diet. Yeah. I remember one of the,
one of the countdown shows Bj when he was,
uh,
he had apparently burned off
too many calories, he said,
so it's time to load up.
So we had one of those local Moco
burgers with an egg on it and everything.
And you get fucking get your,
your,
your Mac Salad and you're fucking
chicken Katsu or, and it's just,
they, you know, they're, they are
island people. They're fucking crazy.
And it's just so entertaining
to hang out with them.
I just go out there and like, oh my
God, okay, what are we doing today?
Do you think you'd live there though?
Yeah, but like Bj, I want to move to Reno,
you know, and that's
pretty just, you know,
cause it's might be the only guy on the
planet that wants to move to never heard,
never heard in my life.
And it's, it's fucking, you
girlfriend lives there. Yeah.
And we'll then move. Yeah.
But it's, you know, it's wilderness
enough where you're, I mean,
you fucking seen Nevada parts in Nevada
and you're like, where the fuck am I?
Right. Yeah. There's parts of Nevada
where they have crazy elk hunting. Yeah.
Where there were bugling elks and you
hear these elks like fucking 1200 pound
beats come rolling over the hill.
30 and 40 of them at a time.
Her cousins are all trappers and hunters,
hunters out there.
They're like the two of the
best young guys out there.
Isn't that funny that people don't think
about that when they think of Nevada?
I think of only Vegas nuclear waste.
The Safari Club is the biggest fucking
incredible club in the credible nature
out in the back. Yeah. Yeah. Oh well,
especially up near Lake Tahoe is,
it's fucking 7,000 feet and you go hiking
and you go running and do whatever the
fuck you wanna do. You get in shape
quick. Yeah. And it's beautiful too.
It's inspiring how
beautiful it is, man. My,
my grandparents have a spot right on
the lake down there and it's, it's,
it's fucking incredible. I mean
it is so nice. And you know,
I just pulling in grandma's yard and go,
go down to the dock and just like,
oh and plus my, no, my girlfriend, she's
the face of Harrison Harvey's up there.
What is that? She's the big
hotels up there. Oh she's,
they pay her to just fucking stand
around. Oh that's cool. So to sweet Gig,
deep down, it doesn't suck. Isn't all
meth down up there though isn't Reno?
There's parts of Reno that is shit,
don't get me wrong there.
Knows Reno nine one one there.
But like if you go to the [inaudible]
out the mad cat hilarity like the free
fun.
If you go to the free fund like the river
and people that blow up mattresses is
going down and shit. But
if you can just, you know,
say that's hilarious and then kind of,
you know,
have your own life and do your own thing.
I just liked seclusion.
I'm I becoming more secluded and,
and again back to like Bj has, he,
he'll go stir crazy and then
he'll go train over here.
I'll go train in Brazil and he gets away
and get away from your family and kids.
Yeah. Yeah. I think that also too,
you live in a place in Orange
County that is super congested.
There's so many people came there.
Yeah. I'm not a fan of that either.
So when you go somewhere else,
like take a a place where like Reno,
which is just,
especially at near Tahoe,
where it's just all nature and
beautiful and you feel like
you feel it's relaxed, you're not
stuck in traffic for 20 minutes,
you're going to go two miles in
20 minutes. I mean, that's a,
if you're in Vegas and you know you're,
you're trying to go down the strip and
you're trying to go from one in this trip
to the other end on a Friday
night, good fucking luck. You know,
it might take you hours. Yeah. And
that's, that's every day in Orange County.
Every day. I mean, you can go,
you can get traffic in Orange County
at four o'clock in morning. Literally,
I'm on another run into traffic.
So I got here an hour early because I
never know I was in fucking Irvine and I'm
like, oh, I got to go now. Yeah, what?
I texted you, I think it was like
two in the afternoon. I'm like,
I wonder if that's enough time for him
to get out here. Yeah, seriously. Yeah,
it's so fucking stupid.
So you go to a place like Reno and
you feel that that nature and you go,
I could live like this though.
Like why would I got fucking
hot girlfriend I got,
she got a cute kid, I got a cute kid
and cost of living is super low and I,
all I need is a nice little all wheel
drive Subaru or something or an Audi and
just hit that fucking Kingsbury grade
while blah blah blah. Pop Up, pop up,
you know, which you would
you train up there? Yeah,
I would do my training camps down
in, in uh, orange county still.
But if I could just get away and I
mean there, there is Jim's up there.
What does their high level gyms?
There's a,
there's a reno or Nevada Moy Moitai, which
is I think the best gym up there. Um,
and they have Charles Gracie Jujitsu. She,
they've got some good black folks. Nice.
And that's all in Reno. Yeah. And
then when the people live in Reno, uh,
it's getting bigger and it's getting,
I mean like the food's getting really
good really? And yeah, there's, there's,
and every, you know, my
girlfriend, like I said,
it's kind of the face of the area
and she's always around other hot.
That's what I get to see it get
to see hot women all the time.
She runs a promotional company,
so it all makes sense now. I understand.
I want to read, I didn't get it.
The cat,
the caliber of ask that comes out of her,
even her little town of [inaudible]
is fucking incredible. I'm like, wow,
this place is great. That's interesting
because I think it's biased of course.
But I think, I've never been
to reno, but I think of Reno,
I might've been the arena, but I don't
remember it. But I think of Doug,
Stan hope recorded a CD there once because
Doug likes to go to fucked up places
and record things like he, he did
one of them in Oslo, Norway, like,
oh I fuck do that. They barely even
understood what he was saying. He,
but he recorded his first CD and a v Reno
and the voice that's chalked off on a
list of places I don't need to go to
and listen to that CD. I'm like, yeah,
I don't need to go there. It's changed
very recently where it's becoming cool.
It's becoming kind of Portland dish,
but minus the fucking Douchey.
Let's save the world kind of Shit. It's
like, when did that happen? Recently?
Super recently. I how many years?
Past five years maybe. What caused it?
People probably realize that
people realize that we're
fucking everything up and
we're douchebags and everyone's
like, okay. But it's, it's just,
it's so outdoorsy and it's so,
it's,
it's still got the fucking casinos and
they're just trying to be, become nicer.
But uh,
there's always something going on.
There's only other guys I know that lives
in Reno is a, my friend Remy who's a,
he's, there's a show
called solo hunters. Yeah,
well he goes hunting biopsies of a guide
and he's kind of famous hunter and he
uh,
they,
he goes by himself and just brings like
these cameras and Gopros and shit and
films everything and then edits
it all together. It was crazy,
crazy hunts and he goes on,
I want to kill something with a sword.
I cause that is but not
likely. You're really
good with a sword. Yeah.
I got a black belt in San Suu when I was
younger. Kung Fu Sensu so I was just,
it was just go with weapons.
He was all like threat strokes in growing,
growing shit and like I was
just good with a weapons.
Have you ever like put on the Kendo gear
and done that? No. It looks fun. It is.
What? I'm going to beat the shit out of
each other with pillows on your body.
Well I think it looks like
you're the of sticks. Yeah. Yeah.
David Lee Roth moved to Japan
and he practices Kendall all day.
He does Kendo every day. Cause he's
David Lee Roth. He said he's a gangster.
He's fucking awesome. David,
Dave Dude. Fucking high
kickin and shit. Took his dog.
Yeah, it took his dog got on
a fucking plane at like what?
60 is he 60 moved to fucking Japan.
He's taking Kendo lessons.
It's under some great fucking
Samurai warrior character.
They tried to do it for five West.
That was one of the ones that we,
they tried to do and apparently the
association is unbelievably strict. Real.
It isn't like, oh we have our Kendo
school. We do what we want. No,
it's like the hierarchy's very, very
rigid and they were like, no, fuck.
I just want to,
I want to pick to run at me and just
soon and then just have it slide. Yeah,
that was being in the food. You not want
to pick to run those mother fuckers.
When we were at a to hone
ranch when I was pig hunting,
they had a skull from this one
really big board that they killed.
It was a 450 pound boar and the fucking
teeth were like two fingers and they
were sticking out like this.
He's taught us and that they would
tell you that they run by you.
They just run at you and literally tear
at the side of you. With these tusks,
they use these tusks almost like as
remember those carts as chariots.
He said those wheels blades, tick it
off of him. That's what the the hogs do.
They run by you and you'll see this
will fuck you up. They will fuck you up.
Let rethinking my idea.
Yeah. Don't want to,
you don't want to sort of always
best with the rifle. Yeah. Rifles.
The moon bone Arrow is good but are very,
there's a very small window to get a
board with a bone arrow down with the
fucking spirit. Difficult. Well,
they have difficult a Oregon's to reach
and they also have an incredibly dense
upper body, like their upper body, the,
the thick skin around their neck and Cape.
It's like,
it literally is like some sort of a
like a shield that they're wearing.
Like we touched a when, when I was in
camp there was a, I killed a female pig,
but there was a guy that killed a big
boar and they were explaining to me,
this is why like shot placement is
critical when it comes to archery,
like touch this and it's like a saddle,
like a, like a, like a horse saddle.
That's what it felt like around the neck.
And because they're constantly cutting
each other up and fucking each other up
so they have like this thick
meat all around their body.
Can you do eat that meat or
is that just the shock? Yeah,
I was gonna say it's got to be good.
Well the pork is very good
for especially smoked.
I smoked a ham and I'm telling you, it's
one of the best things I've ever eaten.
It was delicious and super healthy,
much healthier than a pig that you'd be
getting a grocery store because these
pigs are just eating egg corns
and there they're running around,
they're real muscular. So there it's
like a dense rich, dark protein.
Super good for you, man. Meets
all oxygenated and fucking,
if you wind up going up to Reno,
you'll get a lot of elk cause
there's a lot of elk up in Reno.
There's a lot of people that have,
you know, a lot of hunters up there.
I'm sure you can probably
buy it up there too. Yeah,
I would want to go kill it myself. I
would just go with, with my girlfriends,
cousins, they fucking,
that's their thing. They, I,
I want them took me fishing over the
winter and out to the rivers. You know,
we just, he's like, yeah,
throw it there and I missed,
don't wanna throw it right there.
And I missed again. He's like,
give me that through it in
the spot and kind of fish.
Did he see it or you just know where
the pool was and mean? He's like,
and we're driving by and he's like,
we're driving from the highway and it's
a hundred feet down to see the ribbon.
He's like, oh, you see the fish coming
up? I'm like, no man, he's driving. Yeah,
we're driving this train station, the
road bitch. She's like, you see that?
I don't fucking put your fucking eyes off
the river. I'm like, I don't know man.
So we went down there and he, he
just, wherever he tells you to put it,
if you can live,
once you landed in that exact spot,
you pull in a fucking fish and like how
many times have you caught that fish?
He'll look at it and be like, Eh,
maybe not this one. I don't know.
And then like he's like,
I've seen fish with Talon marks
on them that I've caught before.
Talon marks from an eagle funnels
up and Rhea. Oh fuck yeah.
There's a bunch up down in that area.
Wow.
I've seen like 10 in one
spot and in Tahoe. No Shit.
My [inaudible] said my grandparents
haven't had spots all over the lake,
but like right on the lake.
So you just sit in their backyard and the
fucking in the winter especially cause
it's all white, you know, you can
just see these big fucking birds.
I saw my first live eagle last
summer in Alaska. Really credible,
credible Alaska is fucking amazing.
Flew over our boat.
Me and my friend Ari Shaffir. We went up
there fishing and we did a gig up there.
Fucking had a great time.
But when we're uh,
we're taking the boat to
the spot on the river,
he's fucking eagle flew over
our head is huge eagle. Just
big ass fucking legs and shit tucked up.
It's not a big fuck you man.
It's such big birds to fucking snatch
you up and take you home looking for the
same shit. I'm looking for
trying to steal some salmon.
They're so big and there's so many
of them. You see them up there.
The people say they're like pigeons.
Like they think of them as
like pigeons and nuisance bird.
The American Eagle caught dammit. Dammit.
Our national birds of nuisance bird.
That's a problem too because if it got,
if they got so overpopulated they would
never get so overpopulated in America or
doubt. I mean Alaska is not really
America, it's kind of America,
but whatever other Russia.
But if they got down here and the got
that over populated and they started like
stealing cats and shit problem,
like people might be an issue like
the wolves now do in my neighborhood.
I have a problem with owls.
I don't have a problem with owls,
but you know my problems and our problem.
No, cause they'll fuck up some cats.
Like if you leave your cat outside the
and the owl catches your cat slipping the
little fucking swooped down.
Owls.
People don't think of owls as being
like vicious predators. They are.
They're ruthless.
Hallberg big owls are big.
I had an album on my back porch is
motherfucker was three feet tall.
It was like this tall. There's
sitting there. I'm like, God damn.
I didn't know owls with that big
creepy fucker was backwards head.
What else I want time to next.
There was a four foot,
four and a half foot beating the shit out
of my sister's dogs here.
This cheese Mac and the shit out of Ge.
Yelping I'm like, I had to go out
there and save my sister's dog. Do it.
Recognizable fucker. Oh good.
You issued their fucking vicious.
Have you ever seen a video of Kevin
Rose? He's from a, what does that,
what does he from dig from Digg dot.
Kaiser.
He created dig and his dog was
getting attacked by a raccoon.
So he picked a raccoon up and
they got it on security camera,
picked a raccoon up and threw
it down a flight of stairs.
But it's pretty fucking gangster.
The way he does it.
He grabs a raccoon bites back to see if
he can find it, see if we could find it.
He's got it.
And your rabies walk.
Rabies just loved his dog so he
just fucking did it. You know,
he just had to do it and this is,
you had it.
Oh Shit. That's so the,
he runs up to the Rep.
Isn't that crazy thing. Look at that.
Thinks leg and twirling fucking balls,
man.
He's got balls do cause he
didn't like try to underhanded.
He brought it behind his head.
He fucking hated that raccoon.
That guy's bad ass.
They will fuck your pets
up if you are not careful.
That is wild man that he did that.
Meanwhile the raccoon probably
walked it off like it was nothing.
This is my dog toaster
crying and yelping and pain.
I discovered a raccoon attack. Him. I do
not occur. It encourage animal violence.
I want to get the wild animals far away
from us as possible. Toasters. Okay.
But it has some bite marks.
Look at it.
There's a dog and the
raccoon are going at it, man.
And he sees that shit and he just runs
up and grabs that motherfucker and whips.
It runs after it. Bad motherfucker.
Kevin Rose is a bad
motherfucker that is gangster,
but it looks like he owns a poodle.
I'm just
throwing that out there. A little count.
I'm not even sure if he's straight.
So you know, whatever, whatever.
He went after that record and after he
threw it, he said, fucking crazy prick.
That guy's a mad man. I
ticked that raccoon. Turn
them into a hat. Oh done deal.
Stomp on his little head.
And my dad's from Kentucky.
He was hunting since he was like three.
He's eaten everything. He is in the woods.
Oh a million times. Raccoons,
squirrels, snakes, all kinds of shit.
I beaver when I was in Wisconsin and I
don't mean what you think. [inaudible]
I got a, I had a beaver. Stu,
Steve Rinella a he slow simmered a beaver.
He caught a beaver.
Killed. It turned its mitten.
It's a body and a mittens.
Saw that on your Instagram. The same
beaver. I ate some of that beaver.
It was really delicious. Yeah. Tasted
good. Tastes like beef. Like, like,
like a beef pot roast. That's
what it tasted like. Man.
I hate I have eaten. No,
no, no. I will eat anything.
Like I will eat anything.
And my dad,
he did eat things that I
will not touch and my mom,
he thinks like I have
parents that are even worse.
I'm know for reading anything like balloon
in the Philippines and you know, it's,
I mean all kinds of shit doesn't
really, I don't, doesn't bother me.
I refuse to eat what I drink is
holding a turtle blood one time. Yeah,
it was like a thing for the gym.
Like really? When I fuck Yoka Shin,
they said it's a thing in our
gym first they gave me a curry.
That was so, it was the hottest thing
I've ever eaten and I like spicy food.
It burned from like the moment all you
could feel what all your intestines where
like it when all the way through my
intestines burning everything and I just
kept eating it and other guys
reading and they were meditating.
They had towels on their
heads like blocking out the
pain and they're crying and
stuff and I'm eating it. I'm
just mad. It's fucking hot.
And I just kept eating it
and the instructor turns
to our translator and goes,
ah,
that is some shit in Japanese and the
instruction that Translate Trans People's,
you're very tough.
A lot of people pass out.
I'd have to go to the emergency room
like a lot of people die. They were like,
what? They have to pump them or they'll
die. It starts burning and I was like,
are you fucking kidding me? And I finished
it. I May 8th of thing. How's your ass?
Oh my goodness.
That's a great question. I don't even
think about that. Burned on the way out.
It didn't burn as bad as it did on the
way down. Like it was burning like,
oh this is uncomfortable and not,
Oh shit, I'm in big trouble burning.
And then the next night we went to this
old school Sushi place in the middle of
Tokyo and they have a thing
where it's like a, a Mug,
like a beer Stein full of turtle books.
Do you have this turtle soup?
And they put the blood in this thing
and they usually mix with alcohol,
but I don't drink.
So they had to mix it with some kind of
juice and they mix it all up and like
here you go. And I'm like, all
right. And I drank this whole mug.
It turtle blood man, just chugged
it. Tire Stein of turtle blooded,
Chug the whole thing. How many
ounces? Like 1216 year mug.
Like a Beer Stein to like 20 feels
a lot. Like it was a while. Yeah,
it was a lot. And I just chugged it,
man. I was like, all right, here you go.
And sit it down. So he's like, it actually
wasn't bad. It wasn't that strong.
So it tasted like whatever.
It looks like an apple juice or something.
It's usually put booze in
there and I won't drink.
So they had a like apple juice mixed with
the turtle blood and tasted more like
apple juice. So I just drank the whole
thing. Oh, so it wasn't bad at all then?
It was actually show me,
no I didn't.
I didn't think the blood
tastes was that strong,
but I'm sure it would gross out a lot
of people that couldn't get through it.
I didn't really care. Your mouth was
still burning from the fucking yeah,
from that curry. I didn't tell you
shit man. That was the deal. They put,
they just hated us
pretty bad on that shit.
They cut out a lot of it on the show was
because you could only fit so much in
the TV show. Like when I went to
Gracie, who? Martha in Brazil,
I fought everyone in the room for
three and a half hours, Wah. Okay.
By the time I was done, I was like that
Gabe written over my face like, and no,
we're dealing, you know, 15 black belts.
It wasn't like how many times did you tap?
I don't even remember because the
first 45 minutes I'm doing fine.
And then after that you just bought.
It just starts giving even out on you
and they don't stop and they're all,
and then I look around and I realized
that nobody else is fighting but me,
I like, I'm waiting and they're all
waiting on the mat just to face me.
And so I'm just riding the snake for
three and out. Three and a half hours.
That is some annoying shit when you see
it sitting there waiting to roll with
you and he's not rolling.
He's waiting for you to get tired.
And then as soon as your turn is up,
the bell rings and then he's like,
you want to go? And you're like, what are
you been doing for the past 10 minutes?
Imagine a whole class full of
that guy. And I mean, like I said,
15 black belts and it wasn't, I mean
this is the original Gracie academy.
It wasn't like a bunch of chumps here.
I mean these guys were amazing.
It's good as it gets.
And the next day I came in and they
did the exact same thing to me.
Oh my goodness. I couldn't, I wasn't
moving great by the end of that.
And then I got not food poisoning.
They made me swim out in Ipanema beach.
They want a shot of me
swimming and they said, okay,
we want you to swim from here
to here. And I went, all right.
And then that night I got sicker
than I've ever been in my whole life.
The sound guy got sick listening
to me puke. He was like,
he was holding the mic
going like he got sick.
He literally got sick listening to you,
you get sick because I was shitting in
puke and like from the water and your
mouth,
those fathers,
they had me swim where the
favela runoff goes. Nobody told,
like the producers
didn't research anything.
They just said swim from there to there
because it would look good. I went,
all right, fine. Well
that's fucking Brazil.
And I went to go. I went, yeah,
I swam out there and the the
local looks at me and he goes,
you can't swim out there. That's
where the favela runs off. And I went,
ah, and they go, no, no, no, you can't
swim up there. He goes, American, Nah,
you can't swim out there. And I'm like,
Oh shit. That's why I got so sick.
You swam and Favela Shit.
And the next day I had to fight the guy
for the final fight and fight quests.
And I, I remember standing there and I
was so sick that I was sweating. You know,
you're so sick,
you're swaying like you can't stand still.
And I was swinging around and
because they wanted footage to cut,
I fought the guy for 2024 minutes.
Oh my.
Like it wasn't like a seven, you
know, I was a pro bowl at the time.
It wasn't a seven minute match.
That is two or three times. So,
and this guy was like, he was
amazing. Not only was he really good,
I was sicker than a goddamn dog, so it
was just terrible. So that happened a lot.
Like there are a lot of things, it just
didn't make the cut. There were like,
that sounds like, oh, that's
the show. It was rough. Man.
That's the problem with having a show.
It's got to be an hour.
It's got to fit between this time.
Like no,
it should be fucking hours and hours long.
He should have to watch all of it.
Yeah.
Just watch what I mean,
that sounds like a lot of entertaining
shit went down a lot of stuff.
I mean it was cool man.
It was an experience of a
lifetime doing that kind of stuff.
I would have liked to seen those video
of the guy telling you that that's where
the favela runoff goes.
I was so knowing that you were sick,
doctor Brazil and I was like, no,
it was when I was, I'd gone back to,
I trained with Nova neon Donna
Brazil. Oh, on that trip. And uh,
I was just down there for vacation.
I did an m one show and decided to
stay for a few weeks. And uh, yeah,
I went back to that beach
and a local set. No, no,
you can't swim out there
and shit. Water. Like fuck.
They missed that. I got so God damn
sick. It was horrible. Yeah. That's not
in, yeah, probably. I was in the
emergency room in Rio and I can't,
I was lying on the floor cause I couldn't
sit up and a doctor came by and said,
get him in a room right now and
I'm in an emergency room in Rio.
So it wasn't like, you know, I'm
out in the middle of nowhere.
Like this is it packed
emergency room in a major city.
And they went get him an emergency
room right now. Get him in a room,
getting my next day, the next day.
God Damn. Oh God. It was all it was.
I felt like ass, you should have
just shit all over. What I did,
I kept my cabby bubble buttle
clenched up and kept rolling,
man. You know, that sounded like it
was a fun show to do though. It was,
it was a blast to do. It really
was. It really was. It was, um,
it was just the disconnect between
the,
the people who made the show, the
producers and everything weren't fighters.
They weren't martial arts
didn't understand anything.
And, and right, so Doug got,
when are we doing Kilcoyne in Japan.
He got concussed so badly. He didn't,
he couldn't see out of his eye.
He had a hemorrhage behind his eye and
he couldn't see out of it. And, and they,
they would go to me and go, well, what
do you think's wrong with Doug? And I go,
I'm not a medical professional.
I can't, you know,
his knee was like grapefruit sized or
like a melon sized. And they were like,
what's wrong with him? And
I go, I, I'm not Dr. Smith.
I go there like nine things that could
be wrong and to create those symptoms.
He needs an MRI. And they
went, oh, he'll be all right.
And he fought like they didn't,
this wasn't,
they weren't staff reginae
they could've been anything,
but they did these warrants
sanctioned athletic events.
So they didn't test.
If we were,
if we could get out there and
fight, we fought, that is up.
They just didn't have any, that's the
problem with reality to is there's no,
you know, I remember, you know, a pretty,
she doesn't know like is that safe?
They don't know.
We shot on the edge of the volcano one
time and there are all these signs going,
like there's, there was, there was a, uh,
like a guard rail to keep it from going
out with this poisonous gas. Well,
the camera guy goes,
I'd be great shot if we got out
there and this is in Indonesia.
And he just turns to the, the guy,
the ranger and says, can we just go,
we're just gonna go right out there.
Just is that cool?
And the guy just kind of threw his hands
up on, yeah, go ahead. And he goes,
and then, so we went out there and he
goes, all right, well how about that one?
And so we did the shot and
I turned around and we are
60 yards behind. Do Not Cross poisonous
gas. Don't go over this slide.
And the camera guy,
it's about talk to his dude into
letting us get all the way out there.
And the guy starts talking and our
trans or turns to us and goes, yeah,
there are rivers of poisonous gas around
where you're shooting if you fall,
that's it for you basically.
And I'm like doing stuff on the top of
this mountain. And they're like, yeah,
if you follow that, that's it for you.
And the producers don't give a fuck.
They do not. It's good for the show. God
Damn it. Get your ass out there and do it.
That's the attitude of reality TV.
So it was this combination of
fighting and reality TV. So it was,
it was interesting because they don't
know that. And I had to go, hey,
Doug needs a concussion check. And they
went, well, how do I go? Or I said,
we need concussion checks after we
fought five guys in the CALC isn't final.
I said, we need concussion checks. And
they said, well, how do you know? I said,
listen to me, I just fought
five guys in a row. I, you know,
I'm telling you we need to get checked
out to make sure we don't have a
concussion. And they're like
fighting me on it. And I went, look,
we need to go to the restroom when
we need get concussion checks.
We both got kicked in the head, they
were fighting, you'll fine. But I,
the whole point is I shouldn't
know the difference. You know,
if a guy's telling you doesn't he
concussion check, it needs to concussion.
So they went and they took us there and
Doug blew his nose because of blood in
his nose and his cheek starts
blowing up like a balloon.
He had cracked or orbital bone and so
air was getting out through his cheek and
so he goes, is there something
wrong in my cheek? And I hit it.
I pushed it and it was going like a
rice krispies cause there was air, air,
air bubbles in there. And I went, I think
you cracked your own little Barb wrote.
It's like, Ah Shit. Okay.
And then we fought again in like 10 days
were in another country, the same shit.
It's taught again with a broken orbital.
Two days later we had 10 days
between shoots. That's exactly.
So that's when we started the
next one down. Tough fuck man.
I was just our lives man.
How old were you then?
I turned 30 during the show,
so I was 29 for most of it.
So you were young enough to be talked
into something really fucking stupid.
But I also, but also like
defensively, like the pro Doug
really got beat on my, my,
my cohost on the show because
I have fought professionally
when I'm in deep shit
in the show, I would put my hands up
and move my head and, and you know,
I've been around the block enough to
know that when I was outgunned I was
fighting a heavyweight.
Okay. If I can cover up,
cover up and not get
hurt straight defense,
he had no idea how to do that
and would just get hammered.
When I was living with his background,
none, he was a, he was a military guy.
He had been,
he had been in Iraq and,
and had been a bodyguard in Iraq
and had done some amateur fights.
So he just didn't have the
wherewithal to go, you don't,
when you're fighting six guys,
I'm going to make it look
good for three of those guys.
And then for the rest I'm slipping
and moving and you know, I'm,
I'm working on my, using my defensive
skills. He didn't have that skill set.
So when the water got too deep,
he would just get hammered and hammered
and I'd have to talk to producers and go,
you can't. One time we were in
Indonesian and he's a real jovial guys,
a lot like use those jokers,
smaller guys who he's funny
and he was just depressed,
like to the point of like he wasn't
the same dude and the producers went,
what's wrong with Doug?
And I said,
he's getting beaten up every fucking week.
You can't put him through this
physically and mentally every week.
Like these starting to break
down and we're, I'm like,
week six, whatever it was.
I go, he you, you can't, it's like at
the gym, like when you get hazed. Yeah,
that's fine.
If you hate the guy every day for a month,
he starts just fallen apart or you,
you can't,
I mean every good coach
knows that like you put,
you go with guys or higher level,
but there are certain point
you don't give him those,
give them those times where he's feeling
good and if you don't have those,
you start breaking down.
And Doug started just breaking down.
Well there's also right,
your whole system gets fucked
up cause of head trauma bad.
That's what they're finding now
and out mad about head trauma.
Head trauma to a tear gland just doesn't
produce the chemicals needs when it
gets smashed by a Shin kick,
it just doesn't work.
The ranch is the big argument about this
TRT shit cause they're saying if these
guys need TRT thing wrong cause they're
getting kicked in the head all the time,
it's either that or steroids or
there's a medical issue on top of that.
So how many people have that
medical issue? It's a small
percentage. Most of them.
Hypo Gandy, isn't it? Yeah.
Going at a homeowner, either.
Most of them see their steroid abuse or
they've getting hit in the head too much
or weight cutting. Weight
cutting is a big one too. I had,
I had a doctor telling me,
he goes,
no functioning athlete should
need TRT. He's like, if,
if you need TRT, something's wrong. You've
been, your endocrine system is screwed.
There's something that's happened
to fuck you up. Uh, apply. Matt,
you shouldn't be thinking
about TRT therapy until
you're like 45 50 until you're
literally not, you know, I'm not preaching
of Sergeant, I'm getting too old.
It's like a prime athletes
shouldn't have that on.
The only doctors I've talked to
you have given me, they said,
shouldn't happen if you're that
age unless something's wrong. Yeah.
There were guys in the UFC
that had in their 20s yeah.
What, what? Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Maybe
like Antonio Silva because he's got,
he's a very extreme example. This
is a special case period. Yeah.
It makes sense that he would
need it. But you know, it's,
it's a fucking,
it's just such a crazy situation because
they let it through for a while. Yeah.
You know, so we've got, Oh God,
the guy like Chael Sonnen is kind of
like the canary in a coal mine and he's
kind of like one of the
first guys you know,
and had the issue after the
Anderson Silva fight, we said,
they said it was clear but it wasn't
cleared and almost won the title and then
was suspended for a long time and then
came back and then failed that test and
then failed this new test. And so,
but the problem with this new test,
okay,
if the last test he had that obviously
was things to deal with the TRT therapy,
what I've read and the argument is going
to be how does this affect his legacy
and that he had in that,
okay,
did he retire because he knew he
had pissed off of this other test.
Didn't want that,
but come on
public and you know,
it just raises all these questions about,
well he's on all this other stuff.
He knew he took the test already.
The one in Oregon was he retiring because,
oh man,
I pissed off for this one to you and
try and get out. I mean it just castle,
there's a serious doubt on his,
his legacy. When you throw him the,
the new tests it got announced
today. That's huge. Okay.
But do you could question
vandelays legacy? Uh,
a little bit. I mean, we're all sitting
here talking about when Vandelay was at,
his best motherfucker was
juiced beyond. Oh, and we're,
we're sitting here talking about man,
when Vandelay was at his best,
he was a walking pharmacy. We're
assuming that, but that's legacy.
When you see Vandelay Silva,
Joe,
what do you think of this roided
out beast killing people in prime.
Different time. Different time. But
it's still what we're thinking about.
It's still in our head.
It's still part of the conversation we
just had about a prime mentally involved
pharmaceutical products. That's legacy.
Yeah. You got to knowledge. It is,
it's what you talk about. It's still my
favorite. Yeah, exactly what it, man,
I'm put my bitch Vandelay fan till the
day I die. I love the guy to death.
But like I said, when you say
legacy, yeah. You're thinking,
what do I think of when I think of
that? No, absolutely. It's true.
I mean, look, it's something that
has to be considered. And with jail,
you know, there's more than one situation,
more, more than one instance of it.
So it's, you know, it's, it's,
it's a part of his legacy,
but I think Chels legacy ultimately is
going to be more of a self promoter then
even if a fighter, I mean, he's, I think
he's the best shit talker ever by far.
His mouth, his bronze.
Fucking, he's the greatest.
I love his shit. Talking
and it made him, I mean,
you think about he has a victory
over shogun. Huge victory submission.
When the Anderson fight,
the first one,
very close fight gets submitted
in the final round. I mean,
there's a lot of good
moments in his career
leading up to the Anderson Silva fight.
I remember he'd beaten Nate Marquardt
was a great fight, great fight. Uh,
he'd beaten, I want to see,
you should know comedy before
that. Yeah, he'd be, yeah.
Decisions. I mean, you
know, had he, he'd be,
I remember not thinking he had much
of a shot. I remember thinking, oh,
those are good ones. Good solid
guys. But they weren't blowouts.
He didn't destroy those guys.
They were decisioned wins his mouth.
Sold that fight.
Yeah.
I don't remember a lot of people thinking
before he started talking that he had
a great shot.
His mouth made that fight.
I've heard from more than one person that
they were worried that Anderson Silva,
cause remember he had fought tail
slate, this, this goofy, weird fight.
The Damien Maia fight.
Weird kind of fight that Dana was
furious and Anderson Silva and they were
worried about him putting his fight like
on an undercard who's was threatening
put on a car. I don't know how real
that is, but chill went fuck it.
I gotta sell this thing.
And that's when the mouth came out.
Cause he hadn't really done that before.
Yeah,
it was through that fight that
all came out. And his teammate,
one of his teammates or his
old coach told me, he goes,
they were worried Anderson Silva vs shale
was going to be on an undercard cause
there's other performances have been so
weird that they were going to kind of
punish him. So that shale went, fuck,
I got to sell this thing and just started
running his mouth off and made a fight.
That on paper I don't think was super
compelling into like must see TV.
And then it became, and then
it became a thing. You can,
the problem with the character,
and I tell this to fighters all the time,
if it's not you, be
careful. It becomes you.
If it's not you, if you
aren't comfortable, may
him. Miller became a dude.
Mayhem became a person and you to
be a nickname when I first met him.
Now it's a guy,
it's an amalgam I gotta be.
And it's like if you aren't
comfortable being that guy,
please don't start because
you can't just stop.
Imagine not wanting to be Hulk Hogan.
And when people come up and go,
hey, you have to be hokey. He can't be
whatever his name is newer right now.
You can't not feed that back. I can't not
be that guy, so I tell fight. I was like,
Oh, be careful with that
shit. That's once you start,
you cannot stop.
Ultimate warrior died.
The ultimate [inaudible]
in his mom's basement.
[inaudible]
seriously, can't just turn it off that
aren't, she can't go, you know what?
I'm really sick of this stick.
These kids got to be that
guy or else don't start.
Don't create a character to to hyper fight
and for the rest of your life you are
a whole Cogan or you're the ultimate
warrior or you're some character you don't
believe in because it won't go away.
That is hilarious.
We'll talk to you and be disappointed
that man, you're pretty normal. I'm just,
one of the things that that really
I really liked is that people, fans,
a Fike was met me and went,
wow, you're not that different.
Like you're not any different.
Like the show is just you doing stuff.
People who see my commentary and
meet me in real life go, well,
you're not any different really.
I don't have to create a guy that I have
to be when people come up and I've got
to be fight question me.
Like I don't have to be that guy.
Bobcat Goldthwait struggled with that
forever. Bobcat for the longest time,
you know, he, his comedy act,
who would do that?
Like he would delivery it
and then after a while,
I mean it was hilarious,
but after a while he got tired
of fucking doing that. He, his,
he had a great comedy DVD called
is he liked that all the time.
Do you remember that? Bobcat Goldthwait
is, he liked that all the time.
And he's a really, really
smart guy with, you know,
insightful things to say about stuff.
But
I don't think he does that at all
anymore though. Now he's just,
he's allowed to be himself
now, but people, it took,
there was a transitionary period after
he's been on the podcast for, he's great.
I love him. He made a big foot movie,
man. Really? Yeah, a horror movie.
It's good. Let's coming out
soon. We're going to have a,
um, some sort of a release party. I'm in
where we you want to go? Shit. Alright.
Bobcat
Ian and I were in bravo be a screening
somewhere. I'll let you guys know when it,
when it takes place. But uh, Bob,
I seen, I've seen it already.
It's really fucking good.
He had a really good big foot movie.
It's called Willow Creek. That is not easy
to pull off to a really good big Gary.
It got 93 on rotten tomatoes, Asca,
93 fucking percent on rotten tomatoes.
That's huge. Or I am db one
of those things, whatever
it is. But it's, it's good.
It's like a Blair witch style filming.
Like these people that went out looking
to make a film about a big foot and then
they,
you know,
they pieced together this documentary
based on their unedited footage.
It's fucking good. That's crazy. Yeah.
Bob, he's a big believer in big fun man.
I wish big. It was real. I
show two. That'd be so awesome.
I have a theory that if he's real,
he has to be gay.
That's why there's only 10 of them.
Otherwise they'd be everywhere because no
one's eating big foot babies. Who's he?
Who's keeping them from bring days?
Wait too much logic for most people
because most people when you start talking
about you don't, you need a
breeding population of something.
They look at you with this
blank stare and you go,
there has to be enough of them to
have genetic variety and have babies.
This makes sense to anybody.
There's not one big foot one. Oh,
you course you can find,
but you can cut me in population.
Who's then the Pacific northwest. It's so
vast, so it could be thousands of them.
I believe there's about 10,000 Sasquatch
in North America approximately.
When I did that show for Psi Phi
Joe Rogan questions, everything.
I talked to all those
fucking goof balls too.
I talked to those people in depth
for hours. I went squashing.
I went out in the woods with those
people for days poking around,
just poking around, looking at animals.
There's a lot of shit out there.
There's a lot of weird shit
out there like you, you know,
there's things you'll never see.
Like you could live the rest of your
life and never see them outlined or live
the rest of your life and never see a
wolverine. And we know that they're real.
So in their logic they like,
but there are people who are very
credible witnesses who told him,
here's a problem. And I went bear
hunting recently and when I was hunting,
I saw a squirrel for half a second.
I thought that squirrel was a wolf
half of one second. It's like, hello,
it's a fucking squirrel. You asshole.
That highlights, you know,
fairly good light. You know,
it was towards the, you are and
you've been in. Yeah, I'm hunting.
I got a fucking boat.
I'm there for the full experience.
And I thought a squirrel was a wolf.
It was only for a half a second.
But it happened. I really,
I was like, fuck no, it's not
a fucking wolf. You, that's
all it was that much time.
But Oh, that's awesome. That's what
happens, man. You see a bear. Okay.
And you see a bear standing up on
on its back feet, which they do.
I've seen bears do it.
They stand up on their back feet.
It's weird to see because
they're big as fuck.
When you see a seven foot
tall bear standing up and
his back feet and he's near
a tree and if you see that from really
far away and if you're in the woods,
the also is, you're not seeing,
it's not like it's in a field.
You're seeing it in between trees so
you're not getting a good view of it.
You're getting a view of it from what a,
even if it's in the Pacific
northwest especially, it's so dense.
If it's 20 yards away from you,
you're looking at a sliver
of it through a dozen trees.
It least probably more like a hundred
tree is depth. Perception is just fuck,
fuck the perceptions.
Fuck what you're looking at as fuck.
And then if you convince yourself that
it was a guy standing up that was like
black and covered with hair, you're
like, oh my God, I saw big foot.
And then you start painting it in your,
your head that it was big foot.
It's a bear. You dumb
fuck. It's a black bear.
A big tall black bear that was
scratching his back on a tree.
Or we saw them rubbing their
pussies on trees. The females,
they back their pussy up to trees and
they start rubbing their pussies on church
working that they get their ass, they
get horny and they start freaking out.
You guys, he got it. Got
to just find a way. Well,
my favorite is there's nothing
like that in the fossil record.
And they look at you with another blank
stare. Like, Hey, you know, we've,
we've found every creature
that's in the woods now,
millions of years of
versions of those creatures.
We've never seen anything like a big
foot. That's where you're wrong. Yeah.
Yeah. But it is so incredible.
Have you seen one of those things?
It is unbelievably gigantic. There's
no transitional. I've, I've heard that,
that same theory.
There's no transitional species that
they found like to go from there to
anything big foot size. There's no
rugby that big. See the thing about
gigantic pithy goes,
it's really fascinating is they didn't
even know it existed until the 1920 some
guy, was it an apothecary
shop and China and they found,
they found it too unknown primate to
try to figure out what it was asked.
The guy where'd you get this?
They take them to this place,
they find more bones and they find a job
bone that seems to indicate a bipedal
hominid because of the position of
the jaw bone with the animals that are
walking on all fours.
Their jaws positioned differently
than someone standing straight up.
So but based on jaw bones
and a couple of other pieces,
they put together this enormous primate
that they think is between eight and 10
feet tall,
which is what a lot of people say.
The big foot is between
eight and 10 feet tall.
The other thing that's weird is that the
gigantic pikas existed as recently as a
hundred thousand years ago,
documented and lived in Asia,
which is exactly where the Bering strait
connected to the North American land
mass before the last ice age.
So if something did walk cross during
the Ice Age and followed people,
which is what they think happened,
that people walked across that
and came to North America.
That's why when they test native
Americans, they test their DNA.
They find that a lot of them are
related to people from Siberia.
We just kind of fascinating.
So the animal,
if it did exist at the time and did camp,
they don't know if existed, you know,
15, 20,000 years ago, they know
existed a hundred thousand years ago.
That's a long,
long gap.
But if that thing did come and
lived in the Pacific northwest,
the idea is that a small amount
of them would still be there.
There is a thing in Siberia
they call them almost,
that's their word for the wild man,
uh,
that are like either big
neanderthal or small.
Uh,
I can never say the word [inaudible]
again to a pitch again to pick is um, the,
so the Russians had their own kind of
big foot called an Alma and in the mid 18
hundreds,
there's a story of a one called Zona
that they had captured and some crazy
fucker has sex with it and they produced
half Alma kids and their descendants
are still live in this village
and in the steps of Russia. Yeah.
So like stories out there,
totally likely stories out there
probably definitely happened.
I'd fuck big from the end of
towels were short. It's fuck,
neanderthals were short and strong
as shit. Five feet tall, 200 pounds.
Dance as fuck. Yeah, they were
weird. Bill, break your shit.
They were built way more like a
gorilla than they were like a person.
They like Wade dense thick muscles.
And it's interesting that we don't know
what they really looked like either.
We have these ideas that they make,
you know,
we don't know what the
color their skin was.
It's just total speculation as to
what color their skin was. You know,
we don't know what they looked like.
They could've looked way more
like some sort of an ape. Yeah,
we do know that they fucked people
though and that people fuck them.
We noticed there was a
whole lot fucking going on.
Cro-Magnon either push them out or
interbred with them. They're competing.
Fucked him to extinction. Fucked
them into extinction. Man.
Took all those crazy freak neanderthal
bitches and fuck the shit out of him.
Killed their husbands and that's a good,
have a good set of genocide, right? Yup.
Just fucking and killing everything.
It is interesting because they think
now they're starting to think that
neanderthals were way smarter than we
thought they were because their brains are
actually larger than,
than Homo sapiens.
And they thought that those brains that
were larger was to compensate for the
extra muscle mass and all the different
functions that their body was able to
perform that ours warrant because they
were way stronger than people. Yeah.
Then like they would, if we had a
neanderthal that was fighting in the UFC,
he would make who somal par
Horez look like Brad Pickett.
Teach me mean fucking leg left
leg locks and set it out there.
Keep imagine what those
fucking things would look like.
Just thick fucking five foot
tall, 200 pounds. Dense ass,
thick bones, giant elbows and
shit. Fuck you up. Extra long arms,
short legs where you've got to punch
it just catches you and pulls you in.
Our design. Suck so hard. The
JobOne of the modern human,
you know, you see guys get right like
Schilling and mark, Simon Marcus,
perfect shot on the job. Prank shuts
everything off. Not the or. Nope.
It's like punching a forehead.
Part of the reason part of me isn't there
at their heads were shaped differently
is they had extra attachments here.
Dope for muscles.
Also for buying raw meat.
She's chewing through.
Fucking would hide when they
didn't have time to advent knives.
Just fucking chewing through a fucking
woolly mammoths face trying to fucking
take it down. Yeah. That's
not a good way to live.
They don't know what fucking killed
those people off. It's fascinating. It,
they could have also died off
at the end of the ice age.
They think because a neanderthals,
I don't know if they know
when the last ones existed,
but they think it's as recently as 40,000
years ago. Yeah. I think that was the,
the most recent explanations or ideas.
But that's also like 10,000 years ago
is when the woolly mammoth died off and
the saber tooth tiger, and that's also
the coincided with the end of the ice age.
And so there's a bunch of guys that
think that that happened because of
asteroidal impacts that it might have
wiped off gigantic slice of the population
and the end. It's all might've
been too stupid to survive.
I Dunno if that makes any sense though.
I liked the fucking theory better.
Fucking dairy is a little more awesome,
I must say.
Could you imagine if we found neanderthals
doe and they would be technically
human. So if some like shoot the box type
dude went out there and recruited them.
Vandelay recruited them, you
know, brought him back to America.
He's probably the closest
thing to a 20 Anatol.
What'd you think about Vandelay running
out on his drug test? That stupid.
That's unreal. And, but the idea of I ran
out cause it was on diuretics. I don't,
come on, that's, I don't that
it's a little fishy dude.
And you know,
it's also coming from a guy who we sort
of already decided strongly suspect in
our nonmedical. Opinion's been rumored
according to our friend Phil Baroni.
He believes it. I know people who
have seen the contracts. Yeah.
And who were told by officials
that we test for these drugs,
but we don't test for steroids.
Well Jason Chambers,
they told him to get on steroids. Yeah.
They wanted them to get up to 185 pounds.
Chase is like a weight on one 71 70
right now. And there was like a bigger,
you'll one 85 much bigger Jamus on wow.
Come kind of come.
Yeah. They told him to get on
steroids. They don't, didn't pride.
They did not play it man. And he
was like, fucking, I don't think so.
This is not a good idea. The
best idea. Yeah. But those
were interesting times, man.
Like one of my favorite times ever.
I used to love getting up in
the middle of the night or,
or staying up in the middle of the night
and watching those cards take place.
Live from Japan, like, yeah.
What time would they start?
It was totally like stupid late at night.
Right?
I would give the tapes from little Tokyo,
but the,
at the like little rental stores that do
Japanese stuff, that's how you get them.
That's how I see good. I was at UCLA man
and I would ride my bike to downtown.
I didn't have a car at the time and I
would go to these video stories and they
would barely speak English and I would
go, I remember saying like, I want,
I've used MMA didn't really exist
at the time. It was like pride.
And he looked at me and he goes and he
didn't really understand me. Hey Pride.
And I said,
yeah,
I remember that man
fucking scream for years.
Go from get was the only words I knew.
And in Japanese five left.
There's only where a new Japanese, but
I looked at him and I go and I go, shit,
I'm trying to think of a name and I just
went room on a Saturday when he goes
and he points to this area.
We had all these shoot and pride tapes,
whole section.
I remember going back there and back
over and over again just to like,
cause they had all of them and
you couldn't find him anywhere.
Optos alumina Sato broken
grappler man room and a sauna.
Charles Taylor flying armbar
to any fucking so cool.
Does Edwards coming up on it?
He would do grappling competitions too.
He was a bad motherfucker. Bad Mama
Jama. He can't cone and beat him twice.
I did it.
Did it.
I just mentioned tournament and flying
fucking triangle like three out of four
people.
What did,
okay,
but think about the level of Jujitsu
then and then the level of guys now,
where do you,
where do you put him?
I think that he was back then he was,
he was at the level we're at now,
almost that level back then.
But he was,
you know,
a lot of those guys that the Japanese
aren't, aren't that strong? No,
not physically imposing. So I think
that's what I have trouble in the US lots.
Once you get the super athletes who are
physically imposing that just get just
as good. Sure. They're
slick. But you know,
and they have that like one shot,
one kill,
I'll die before I give up
kind of attitude. It just,
they just can't deal with the
physical strength of, of, you know,
I'm American fucking
muscle shit like that.
I totally agree with that. I make like
a, you've look at the guys like, uh,
there's no Japanese Mark
Coleman's? No. Fujita was
pretty, he was pretty close like gas, but
it was just a different sort of thing.
All right. That Juno Kid. Um,
but he never panned out to be,
yeah. I mean, well they made
him fight Fado and like, I mean,
how many nights was he in your sheet?
At his first fight? Yeah. You'll,
she didn't his first fight fade or within
the first couple of years that was,
that was another pride thing.
Like they would feed guys to the God damn
wolves freedom to Fidor eight or what
are you thinking? They love that
shit and the knockouts brutal too.
I mean he just really
is helpless and fatal.
It's just sniping him just
Poland back and watching it.
It was exciting to watch. That was, hey
no one put a gun to his head alleged.
I mean maybe they did. I
don't know. Never know dude.
Who's a scandal that getting one
guy with missing a finger do well,
you know it's,
it's,
that was another knock on
Japanese fighters that come
to us and oh there's big
in Japan and they can do well here.
It's big physical wrestlers, man.
It's hard to overcome that.
What that Japanese like you said
kind of balls out submission star.
We're going hard for the submission
if you don't get it. Okay.
I've put your head through the ground.
Also, the weight cutting aspect,
they didn't really,
they weren't cutting weight.
Not nothing like Americans
are cutting weight.
So you would see guys weigh in and they
see the guy they were funding like what?
That's crazy. Like soccer. I and
Matt Hughes. Perfect example.
You Know Matt, he uses a big
fucking welterweight at at
time. I mean he had these,
these garden hose muscles that would
connect the back of his head to
his neck.
Yeah,
just these thick ass neck fucking
country strong and shit and soccer.
I was just not able to deal with that.
Just it was as a different kind of
athlete. Good fucking passing ability.
Good Jujitsu, good Jujitsu.
He was the first wrestler.
My opinion that really learned how to not
just take us down and ground and pound
them,
but learn how to hit things like that
far side arm bar that he hit on George
Saint Pierre. When George Saint Pierre
went for that Komora he had good Jujitsu.
He had, he had real solid
skills, good defensive skills to,
you know like the Frank Trigg, rear
naked choke. He can put guys away.
He could choke guys and that a soccer.
I was just not big enough to talk
with them. She doesn't handle soccer.
I had some good fucking kicks though
too. Big Ass legs, good leg kicks. Fast,
fast,
accurate,
loaded Sato but sato he was
one of the first guys to,
we saw get a little chimney.
He started to go towards the
end of his career or just
when? Called Luna?
Yeah. Yup. Clipped Bang.
Or Am I in their rematch?
Knocked him right out. Yeah.
How about Carl? Who Know How but what
a bad ass mother fucker that guy was.
He looked when he looked good, he looked
fucking nominal. Just super amazing.
And then some days you're just like,
fuck is this guy.
How about when Bj and just charged
at him ran offense, pop, pop juice,
Kale and him within the first 1520
seconds and just left him there.
I mean it was like one of
the, we are just salt. Yeah.
He's just like for the cops get me
like ran out of the cage in the back.
Like what the fuck is he
gone? It's going crazy. Hilo.
I did it for Mana nuts man.
He went crazy man. Do you think
he has a, you know the, the,
the odds are 10 to one against him.
Frankie Edgar,
10 to one 10 to one 10 to one
yeah. Yeah. I'd take that.
Attended one, couple hundred
bucks on it. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
You never fucking know. I mean, especially
listening to what you're saying, man,
listening to what you're saying
about him being in that good a shape.
That was always a thing
that held him back.
And if there's one last
that fucks with them,
it's not the losses to Nick Diaz or
Rory Macdonald guys who were just too
fucking pig.
He shouldn't have been fighting.
Those guys shouldn't have been [inaudible]
70 and now that he's fighting at one
45 and you're like,
wait a minute.
You used to fight at one 70
you fought Machida to a fuck.
What the fuck man, you fought
heavyweight. He has sent me,
Machida was over two oh five but
she was essentially a heavyweight.
It was ridiculous.
And here he is fighting at one 45 is
there ever a guy like that that went from
heavyweight down to one 45
speaking of size disadvantage.
And then he fucking ends up choking out
Matt Hughes and knocking it out. Man.
He knocked him out with one punch.
Him Choking out.
Matt Hughes could have been.
I don't in many ways kind of a worse
thing ever happened to him is that he kept
flirting with one 70
against these gigantic
dudes. That success, I don't
know, maybe set asides too high.
We're going to do that.
Was the Matt Hughes the only guy he
ever beat at one 70 that's interest.
Everybody forgets. Matt Hughes was the
only guy he ever beat. At 170 pounds.
You're going to beat only
one guy going back and it is.
We kept going back to the
well at once. I'm like, Bro,
you just can't physically
handle those guys. Well,
especially George Saint Pierre figured
out a way to tire him out first and then
beat him up. Increase should up and
your grease, your chest or back.
Remember we had that guy that was doing
like Voodoo on them and shit rubbing his
chest and they caught him putting
Vaseline on his back like what are you
motherfuckers doing?
Tended that touching his nipples,
his forehead and his fucking
giving them the choice.
You have grease on your hands.
It's not an interesting about the UFC
too is that they have cornermen men. Um,
but they don't have it. Like boxing has
their own cut men. The UFC they bring,
they have staff cut men that
worked for the entire card.
I think that's probably the
way to do it. Smarter. Yeah.
Cause you run in those Panama Lewis
type situations where Louie Resto. Yeah.
Irish. Billy can come on. Give me the
bottle. I made a, that was the one I made.
Aaron Pryor and prior on the hardwire
Aguayo was fucking so good. Yeah.
The loon resto thing, man. That was,
that was the craziest shit ever. Yup.
What was the dude's name? The Billy
Irish. Billy Collins. Billy Collins. Yeah.
That was crazy. That kid committed
suicide after himself. Drove us,
drove his car into a,
off a bridge for people don't
know what we're talking about.
They took Louie [inaudible],
took the padding out of his gloves.
That was back in the day. We're a boxing
goes were made it a horse hair and a,
they didn't have those foam pads like
they had today and sometimes they still
use those horse hair gloves.
Like that was what, uh,
my Donna was trying to use with Floyd
Mayweather and they were like, pitch,
you're not using these fucking luck.
Did you ever see that video
with Floyd Mayweather?
But the day after with the gloves
got a real problem with Mei Mei,
whether it was putting on goes,
it's real simple when you're
using these mother fucking gloves.
Like it's real sad.
I feel my fucking knuckle went using these
motherfucking glove and you know, uh,
they're like, don't be scared and why
are you scared to be scared? Bitch,
I ain't scared. I have 49 fucking fights.
Right? We're not using these gloves also,
dude, my hands are worth $78 million
without breaking them because,
and not letting him have those gloves.
That was the big hit with a hammer.
Donna's a vicious fucking punches.
But,
so they took the horse
here out of the gloves.
They made a small hole and then pulled
the horse here out and it was essentially
just taped up knuckles and he beat
the shit out of Billy Collins. Fuck.
This was undefeated at the time and
we really go fight or a little more
journeymen and big upset.
His eyes were so badly swollen.
They took a photo after the
fight and the promoter said,
why don't you take it with his
eyes open and goes, those are open.
Like that's as far as he could
open them. I mean, they were like,
isn't that interesting?
That years later MMA fighters
were fighting bare knuckled. Yeah.
Banned for life.
Both banned
for life. Louie Resto and Panama Lewis
and they both did time for assault. Yeah.
And then Panama Louis went to work with
Tyson afterwards but couldn't work.
The corner. CanNot work. The
corner somehow are in his camp,
but couldn't work the corner. He can
train guys. You can't ever corner anybody.
So as he still doing that to this
day, to this day, he's still doing it.
Louie Resto never got it.
A little Billy Collins killed himself,
spiraled into depression, killed himself.
Louie Resto in and out of trouble.
Homeless drug addict.
Never got it.
You know that I saw a documentary
where he tried to talk to,
to Billy Collins Dad, we wouldn't
have it. Oh Mom. The mom forgave him,
the mom and sister and forgave him.
But the dad wouldn't have it. And uh,
he confessed during the,
the thing too that,
that they'd wrapped his hand
and like this plaster stuff,
the same shit that probably are Rito
Margarito shit that was in the fucking two
thousands bleeding out of
his ears. Nose. I mean,
and then he can, that's
fucking right. That's almost,
that's assault with a deadly
weapon. I don't, I don't get why.
And also I never got wide. Louie
Resto and Panama, Louis went to jail,
banned for life.
Margarito gets caught trying to do the
same thing and it's not to the song like
it's not you got suspension, but do
Louie Resto did time for that. I mean,
panel Lewis did. Tom, Shane Mosley
that beat the fuck out of him. Right.
Beat the piss out of them after they
found out they wouldn't let him use the
wrap. They put new raps and he
got the shit kicked out of them.
Shane was like torturing him,
like he was punishing him for
that and that that was it.
It was a great fight for Shane. That was
Shane's last great fight too, by the way.
Totally fucking pistol. Whipped and bad.
Apparently. Shane's a little punchy now.
People who have talked to
them and interviewing them
now they say that it's a,
he had a few too many,
you know,
probably the Margarito fight should
have been the last one didn't help,
but he fought Canelo after that
and fall may with her. Yeah,
and they were their Canelo but Canelo
want apparently was that was the beating
that tough man. Fuck yeah,
and better all the time.
Getting that Floyd Mayweather
fight was a good fight for him.
Taught him a lot of shit.
You got to,
you know when you're in with a guy
like that, then moves like Floyd does.
Until you see that you don't
know what the fuck that is,
you know you're not going to
get that in training. Who's,
who's going to be your sparring partner?
That's undefeated world champion,
one of the eight or 10 best fighters
that's ever walked the face of the planet.
The first time you see something, you
don't want it to be in a fight. Yeah.
You want to have seen that before. At
some point in training, you know, I,
I play chess. Um, I really like,
yeah, that's Billy Collins.
After the fight with his eyes open,
his eyes are open right now.
It's so far that's as good as it would
get. Oh my God. That's so fucked up.
That's so fucked. Jesus. Never the same.
He went blind. Right. He was lost some
of his vision's awesome. His vision,
and he was trying to sue.
He tried to sue basically the
commission for not catching the,
the gloves because his dad at
the end of the fight, you see it,
Louie Resto goes up and shakes hands
with Billy Collins Dad who's his trainer
and he feels the glove and he goes, wait,
hey, hey. And he gets a commissioner,
but he starts yelling,
this club's half the patterns out of it.
He shook hands and felt the glove.
Yeah.
And he tried to sue the
athletic commission for
letting Louie Resto fight with
the pattern move from the glove and
not protecting the sun. So it kept,
Billy comes from fighting
because they were suing.
And so he was just sitting around
and just getting worse and you know,
got depressed and that was all she wrote.
Wow. That's fucking fine. Yeah. Yeah.
And Panama Lewis is this same fucking
guy who gave Richard Aaron Pryor that
bottle,
the bottle he mixed and he came out
against Alexis Arguayo just supercharged.
Yup. Like whatever it was,
it was in that bottle.
Louie Resto said that he used to give him,
uh,
they were asthma pills, crushed up
asthma pill. So you would, you would,
it would get your breathing
back basically. Amphetamines,
Christof Amphetamines.
He used to treat asthma.
Isn't it interesting that both
Aaron Pryor, any more trivia? Just,
just let me know.
Trivia master,
but both Aaron Pryor and Louie
Resto became drug addicts. Yeah.
Isn't that interesting.
And Alexis, shark whale,
Eddie really big struggles with cocaine.
Big struggles killed himself in Nicaragua.
Uh,
well wasn't he like a
politician in Nicaragua?
There there's some suspicion about yeah.
And it wasn't like a gunshot
wound to the chest. Yeah.
Which is pretty weird for suicide.
Yeah. Well that's the official story.
I niggerize he killed himself
while a lot of boxers, especially,
they wind up with depression,
you know,
from just a repeated trauma and cocaine.
Cocaine also means no Bueno.
Who Was it? Um, Arturo Gotti I
saw thinking about his supposedly,
oh, that wasn't no fucking
suicide. That bitch killed them
once.
But what I thought was interesting,
I saw a very evenhanded documentary
about his alleged to aside slash murder,
whatever you think.
And not once did they go,
did they mention pugilistic dementia,
which causes depression and suicidal
tendencies. They wouldn't, didn't once go.
Maybe that hit in the head one too many
fucking times. You know what I mean?
He didn't, they never once brought it up.
I thought it deserved mentioning that,
you know,
his brain had to be putting at that point,
but didn't he have a big, wasn't there
like at some point in time, wasn't there?
Um, during the, the, the, the
incident, whatever killed him.
It wasn't there a head trauma,
a big
he had gotten in a fight that night.
That's why they had argued,
he had gotten in a fight on the street
in Brazil and they interviewed a cab
driver.
The cab driver drove him from where
he was from where the fight was to his
apartment and the guy said those blood
on the back of my seat, they hit,
they had beaten him up pretty good.
Like he had hit the ground and he
had gotten in a fight with all these
Brazilians.
He had been Malvin off at this club and
his wife left him and that's why they
were arguing that night.
And so he had gotten a fight with
like three dudes on the street.
So cab driver said, yeah and there was
blood on my seat. He had, you know,
nobody beat him like,
and then we said all that she had people
beat him up and then now he was beat up
in the cap when he was in the back of my,
my cab and then he was
found on the ground.
And the only thing that
makes zero sense to me,
zero of all the whole story.
I can see both sides of it.
The only thing that makes zero sense is
the wife claimed was seen in the morning
and thought he was asleep.
If you see the photos of Arturo Gotti,
which I have on the ground,
he's dead in a pool of his own blood.
Clearly like you couldn't walk past
this and think he's okay. Well,
in her stories that she saw him and
thought he was all right. He always,
he always finds that's
what they said he was.
He always used to pass out and fall
asleep drunk. That it, I'm like,
I don't know how you could walk past
that and go, ah, he's fine. You know?
Okay honey. Okay. All right, good.
I'll make some coffee and that's,
that's your story, but I hooked up with
the wrong bitch. A very interesting,
it's an interesting case to say that
case. It's, it's a very sad case,
but you know when she got out of jail,
did you ever see the
photos of her out of jail?
She was like smiling and
laughing when they released.
Yeah, that was, yeah, that was, that was
family was not pleased about that one.
Although if I got left, if I got to let
out of a Brazilian Gera for any reason,
I'd be smiling and happy too.
So I don't take, I don't,
I don't hold that so much against it
cause I'd be thrilled that I'm not,
you know, indicted for murder
in Brazil. I'd be thrilled. Um,
he said it kind of fucked up.
No, like he was a guy who was like
sort of, his career was dwindling down.
He wasn't going to be like
the top of the food chain,
Floyd Mayweather type fighters,
but he found another guy that was on
his level and then it became one of the
first trilogy is one of the first series
of fights where both everyone knew
these guys weren't going to win a title.
Yeah.
So it was like one of the first fights
where it was just an awesome fight
because they matched up together. Well,
you know, it wasn't an awesome vibe,
but Micky, Micky Ward wasn't going to
be world champion. Arturo Gotti wasn't,
he had a title at one point in time,
but he wasn't going to
be the best in the world.
Everyone knew and that was the thing
about boxers is we always wanted to see an
undefeated fighter and we always want
to see a guy fight for the title.
Like the thing about rocky Marciano was
always at Marsianno died 49 oh yeah,
he was up best matching. I don't
never lost. Well, in boxing,
that was like the first duo.
Those two guys going at it the first
match up where we knew that they weren't
going to get a world title, but
we still wanted to see it. Yeah.
You know what's,
what's different in combat
sports that's unique in combat.
Sports is different than another,
especially team sports.
Popularity and ability
just don't go together.
They don't know the best guy isn't the
most popular guy in our church. God,
he was that guy that I would pay to
watch that guy fight no matter what.
No matter when,
even though there were much better guys
out there watching Arturo Gotti fight
was really something special
and he got with Micky Ward
and they had that amazing trilogy.
Um,
the problem is God can do you see the
Mayweather fight? That was like humility.
I was like hard to watch as hard
to watch those too many after that,
after the Micky ward trilogy.
Yeah. It was also God,
he had already taken a lot of punishment,
his career and he wasn't,
he just had no business being in
the ring with Mayweather Mayweather.
There's way too sharp in his prime.
Yeah, I mean I think maybe it was better.
I mean, he was so sharp then.
Unbelievable. Great Guy. He's amazing.
Now I don't even know why I'm
saying this is amazing now,
but even like a younger, even faster
version of, of Mayweather, he was killed.
You know what's really
incredible is fucking Hopkins
winning a world title nine.
That's one of the weirdest examples.
Unboxing of all time.
You want to talk about a guy that just
never faded off? No, still wicked good.
I mean knock that Russian dude down in
the 10th round at 49 but style wise,
he's the kind of guy,
if you looked at all his fights,
the big knock on Hopkins and he never
took a lot of risks. You never know.
Never taking damage.
He's fighting it 50 cause he
never took those and talks great.
It's great. Yeah. Yeah.
His brain isn't putting,
I was just amazed that his body's holding
up. It doesn't look totally the same.
Like he doesn't look as muscular.
He's a little more smooth, loose,
a little more soft,
but not much of a difference.
I think it was part of the reason he's
moving up in weight class a lot is,
you know, speed is the first thing to go
and I think he realizes I can beat these
cruisers,
I can outslick these cruisers.
I don't if you'd do that against
Gennady Golovkin guys at middleweight,
the middleweight, Andre Ward,
those guys are fast and I think he,
I think he's smart. He's a really
smart guy, is a boxing Iq was amazing.
I think you realize is I move up,
I cannot slick these guys.
That's a good point
because for middle weight,
the last guy that he had real problems
with is Germane Taylor and Taylor was way
fast, one 61 60 lightening
fast and then, you know,
look, look at the performances that
he's had at light heavyweight and um,
you know, look at what's his name for
Pittsburgh? Uh, the, the, the white kid,
um, uh, Kelly Patrick from uh,
Youngstown on Nice town. Yeah. Kelly
Pavlik was a slower guy. Yeah. You know,
and Kelly Pavlik didn't have that sort
of ethnicity. Him looked like a fool.
It was beautiful performance.
I made him look ridiculous for 12 rounds
and everybody was shocked and he was
doing it at what, like 43 back then
it was like, this is incredible.
Six years later you would think there's
no way he's going to win a world title
six years from them.
But I think that's why he's moving up
and staying in these weight classes where
he doesn't worry about that kind of
speed. Yeah, that's a good point, man.
That's the hardest thing to
deal with at that age. Yeah,
that's a good point because he's so good
at being in the right place to make a
guy move. And you also, you know
how like you see a guy like,
like today we saw like there was one point
in time where cubs wants and winds up
and I'm seeing him getting
ready to throw kick.
It's cause we've seen a guy
getting ready to throw a kick.
We've seen a subtle changes and when a
guy's getting ready to throw a kick and
you could spot it,
Bernard Hopkins,
he's seen so many guys in
front of him do things.
So many guys try to hit him with punches.
He knows what they're going to do before
and they know what they're going to do.
Oh yeah.
So when he's stepping and forcing guys
into positions where he knows what
they're going to do,
once they get into that position,
they don't even know
what they're going to do.
He's like two and three
steps ahead of them.
So because of that boxing
knowledge that he has,
you get to see like this
really pure sort of a like a,
a pure execution of boxing from him.
Dismantling the executioner, but
not anymore. Now he's an alien.
I had to say that he's the alien and
there'd be throwing the softball.
Got to hit it. She called him.
Yeah. He wears a rubber mask.
He goes into the ring with a rubber
it,
where's the rubber fucking alien mask?
He calls himself the alien.
This is officially the longest
podcast we've ever done.
It's fucking five hours boys. It's
midnight. It's after midnight. Wow. Yeah.
So people listening, they've been trying
to get us to stop. It's over folks.
Go have a sleepover.
Follow Jimmy on Twitter.
It's a Jimmy Smith MMA. No. And um, and,
and follow Ian on Twitter,
but is not Ian, his uncle.
Creepy MMA and uncle creepy
MMA also on Instagram.
Or You could see him or wrestle with
a 500 pound barrel. Yes. And uh,
you will see him July 19th,
uh,
taking on Brad Pickett and
dominating in is a flyweight bout.
Yes. July 19th in Dublin
in Dublin. Dublin,
Ireland. Great fucking place
to do a fight. I know. It's
going to be fun. I got my,
I got to bring you a new shirt. I'll
bring you both. Both shirts. Fucking man.
I'm in. I'm in. I ripped off the, uh,
the fighting Irish shirt. Glorious.
Glorious. All right, we'll, uh, thank
you guys. It was a lot of fun. Thank you.
By the invite. Awesome. Awesome fight.
Cub Swanson and Jeremy Stevens was great.
There's a Bernard Hopkins coming
out with this alien outfit. Oh,
that's hilarious. All
right, my friends, uh,
we will be back on Monday with a crash
from the float lab and until then,
go fuck yourselves. All
right. Big Kiss smile
wasn't.